leurs expressions faciales change
[Musique]
loïc et geoffroy de la tulle et sont
deux frères explorateurs animés par une
passion commune l'eau
[Musique]
pour leur cinquième expédition ils ont
choisi de sillonner l'amérique du sud en
side-car à la rencontre des populations
locales
pensant que moi de l'avis de sao paulo a
soif et à la terre de feu inhabitée ils
ont parcouru plus de 14 mille kilomètres
motivés par ces questions notre visage
de l'eau témoins utiles de notre lien la
nature
[Musique]
non
bonsoir à tous bienvenue sur rt france
pour deux heures d'émission nous
décrypterons comme chaque soir du lundi
au jeudi l'essentiel de l'information
avec nos invités en plateau et nos
reporters sur le terrain voici les
grands titres de l'actualité de ce lundi
27 janvier
history pour israël contestée par les
palestiniens donald trump dévoilera
demain à 18 heures son plan de paix pour
le moyen-orient qui selon lui a une
chance d'aboutir un texte qui divise
fortement alors que benyamin nétanyahou
et benny ganz ont reçu respectivement
aujourd'hui à la maison blanche
75 après la libération des camps
d'auschwitz birkenau évènement macro
appelé à ne rien céder face à
l'insupportable regain d'antisémitisme
au mémorial de la shoah à paris
pendant ce temps en pologne le premier
ministre edouard philippe à lui souligné
elle a indiqu alpar d'inhumanité après
sa visite du camp c'était il y a 6 ans
l'usiné goodyear d'amiens nord fermé
mais le volet judiciaire lui loin d'être
achevé demain après des années de
bataille ce sont plus de 800 ex goodyear
déterminer qui ont rendez vous devant le
conseil des prud'hommes semaine
historique pour le royaume uni j - cat
avant le break site la séparation a lieu
vendredi entre londres et bruxelles
en visite à dublin le négociateur en
chef de l'union européenne michel
barnier mettant en garde contre une
rupture brutale
c'était à son retour d'israël dans
l'avion la semaine dernière le président
mais cran provoqué l'ire de la droite et
de l'extrême droite en faisant le
parallèle entre guerre d'algérie et
chaud à une comparaison afin d'afficher
sa volonté de mettre en terme confie
mémorielle en france sur la question de
la guerre d'algérie un exercice de
relecture de l'histoire auquel le chef
de l'état devrait procéder au nom de
l'état quitte en heure des certains ce
sera l'objet de notre face à face ce
soir
[Musique]
donald trump et bmi netanyahu doivent
donc s'exprimer demain depuis la maison
blanche au menu le plan de paix des
états unis pour le moyen-orient un texte
encore non dévoilé mais déjà jugé
historique par l'état hébreu écoutez les
précisions à tel aviv de notre reporter
thomas bonne et les yeux sont rivés vers
washington et l'annoncent à venir de ce
fameux deal du siècle est tel qu'il est
présenté par le président américain
donald trump en consultant les premières
fuites qui circulent ici dans les médias
israéliens on peut s'attendre un plan
qui serait calqué sur les mesures
souhaitées par benyamin netanyahou et
son parti et ce n'est pas un hasard si
le premier ministre israélien qui est en
déplacement à washington a eu des mots
très élogieux à l'égard du locataire de
la maison blanche estimant qu'il était
je cite le plus grand ami qu'israël
n'ait jamais eue alors ce plan a été
élaboré en secret depuis maintenant près
de trois ans notamment par le gendre de
donald trump et selon les premières
mesures qui circulent dans les médias
israéliens il pourrait appliquer la
souveraineté totale d'israël sur de
nombreuses colonies et sur l'ensemble de
la ville de jérusalem ou encore demander
la démilitarisation complète de la bande
de gaza en contrepartie les états unis à
investir et à hauteur de 50 milliards
dans les territoires palestiniens et
dans les pays arabes voisins
ce qu'un plan qu'il est d'ores et déjà
rejetée par les palestiniens à l'image
du secrétaire général de l'organisation
de libération de la palestine qui menace
de se retirer des accords d'oslo des
accords qui avaient été conclus dans les
années 90 il faut dire que les
palestiniens n'ont pas vraiment été
conviés aux discussions et qu'il rejette
de toute manière tout dialogue avec
washington depuis que donald trump a
décidé de déplacer l'ambassade des états
unis dans la ville de jérusalem alors on
peut peut-être s'attendre à des
manifestations dans les territoires
palestiniens dans les jours à venir
et certains dirigeants du hamas estime
même qu on peut se diriger vers une
nouvelle intifada
et pour en parler nous sommes avec un
club blanchemaison expert en relations
internationales bonsoir claude blanche
maison et d'être avec nous en direct sur
rt france pour bien qu'on comprenne qu
est-ce que soit donald trump selon vous
quelle politique suit précisément
le président américain je crois que la
décision la plus importante que donald
trump est prise en ce qui concerne les
relations avec israël c'est évidemment
de déplacés l'ambassade des états unis
de tel aviv jérusalem
il n'a pas créé un effet d'entraînement
parce que à part le guatemala je ne
pense pas qu'ils aient beaucoup de pays
qui est suivie mais évidemment c'est un
décision majeure une transgression
d'ailleurs des résolutions des nations
unies
mais voilà là le pays le plus puissant
du monde décident que son ambassade ne
sera plus à tel aviv qu'elle sera à
jérusalem est évidemment depuis cette
décision et son application
les palestiniens considèrent qu' ils ne
peuvent plus véritablement négocier quoi
que ce soit avec les états unis
d'amérique
alors président trump a pris d'autres
décisions notamment celle de sortir du
traité que pourtant son prédécesseur
avait signé et que tous les membres
permanents du conseil de sécurité plus
ta grande l'allemagne avaient signé à
savoir le traité sur le nucléaire
iranien
c'est ce que demandait monsieur
netanyahou qui n'avait pas de mots assez
sévères contre ce traité et monsieur
trump la dénoncer et a sorti les amis de
ce traité et puis troisièmement le
président trump a également déclaré que
dans le fond les nouvelles colonies ça
n'était pas nécessairement contraire au
droit international
alors que l'avis des spécialistes c'est
qu'en effet c'est contraire au droit
international et aux résolutions des
nations unies
donc qu'en effet c'est une politique
très pro netanyahu très pro israélienne
ou et non parce qu en israël il ya aussi
les mouvements politiques qui ne sont
pas sur ses filles et qui considèrent
qu'il faut faire la paix parce que si on
ne fait pas la paix qu'est ce qui se
passera à l'avenir et il n'y aura plus
la thèse des deux états et s'il ya un
seul état
que fait-on des palestiniens est ce
qu'on va les faire voter avec les
israéliens avec leur dynamisme
démographique
c'est un risque que peut être que
probablement aucun gouvernement
israélien ne
apprendre de quel type d'accord
parle-t-on alors ici il s'agit d'un
accord qui probablement donne un certain
nombre de satisfactions juridique à
israël probablement l'annexion de la
vallée du jourdain
l'annexion de certaines certains
territoires où il ya déjà des colonies
peut-être d'autres choses comme le
désarmement de la bande de gaza comme ça
a été dit par votre journaliste on ne
sait pas ce sera ça demain soir la
contrepartie de tout ça c'est une sorte
de plan marshall pour la palestine c'est
à dire beaucoup d'argent beaucoup
d'investissement sauf que évidemment les
palestiniens ne seront pas d'accord
puisqu'ils n'ont pas été associés à la
confection de ce plan et que l'on le
fond ils disent qu'ils ont envie d'être
achetés et que en réalité ils sont
toujours dans la configuration qui
découle des accords d'oslo c'est à dire
la construction d'un état palestinien
ils ont d'ailleurs averti que si ce plan
dont on ne connaît pas encore les
détails étaient mises en oeuvre il
sortirait des accords d'oslo ce qui
serait grave parce qu'ils les accords de
partage des responsabilités notamment
sécuritaire entre israël et l'autorité
palestinienne donc ce serait évidemment
très grave
donc tout ça va se dérouler dans les
prochains jours aujourd'hui le président
votre oeuvre soir benyamin nétanyahou
ensuite il va recevoir beenkens qui est
le leader de l'opposition
tout ça dans un contexte un peu
surréaliste puisque en israël il va y
avoir des élections au début du mois de
très bientôt au début au début du mois
de mars et que par ailleurs la procédure
de destitution impeachment poursuit sa
route au sénat taylor donald trump
l'huile a déclaré aujourd'hui il espère
obtenir in fine et le soutien des
palestiniens ce que c'est une chose qui
vous semblent crédibles faisable encore
une fois le pays le plus puissant du
monde met sur la table un plan qui est
son plan
avec beaucoup d'argent et il pense que
ceci peut marcher alors effectivement on
peut être un peu un peu sceptique
d'ailleurs ce n'est pas la première fois
que les qualités diplomatiques de
monsieur trump sont mises à l'épreuve
puisque jusqu'à présent sa démarche
vis-à-vis de la corée du nord n'a pas
produit de résultats sa démarche
vis-à-vis de l'iran n'a pas non plus
produit de résultats très positifs et
que là ce qu'on peut crainte c'est qu'il
y est un échec diplomatique américain
mais probablement avec des effets
escomptés sur le plan électoral en
israël sur le plan électoral aux états
unis justement oui effectivement
certains accusent d'ailleurs donald
trump devoir éviter la destitution avec
cela en ses détracteurs évidemment et
d'aller en prison concernant le premier
ministre israélien que peut faire la
communauté internationale puisque on
sait que notre hump appel à cette
communauté à soutenir ce plan que
peut-être faire on va voir il ya des
discussions en cours au sein de l'union
européenne bien entendu ce plan n'a pas
été véritablement concerter avec l'union
européenne
c'est un plan américain qui a fait
l'objet de concertation avec les
responsables israéliens probablement
avec quelques autres responsables dans
les pays voisins mais on ne sait pas
exactement lesquels et l'union
européenne va avoir à prendre une
position et sa position sera
probablement comme pour le déplacement
de l'ambassade américaine de tel aviv à
jérusalem nous ne souhaitons pas aller
dans ses devoirs
j'imagine que l'union européenne
souhaitera respecter l'ensemble des
règles édictées par les nations unies
peut-être quelqu'un prend 21 jours
l'initiative de convoquer une nouvelle
conférence internationale avec toutes
les parties prenantes dans ce conflit
entre israël et la palestine et toutes
les parties prenantes ça veut dire bien
sûr les cinq membres permanents du
conseil de sécurité
tous les membres permanents du conseil
de sécurité mais aussi tous les pays de
la région il ya un point qui est très
important évidemment pour l'union
européenne mais pas que c'est cette
solution dite à deux
et à ce qu'elle va ressurgir il va
surgir en tout cas dans ce plan de paix
selon vous l'union européenne est très
attaché à cette solution à deux états il
est clair qu'elle va être durement
affecté par le plan américain puisque
dans le plan américain on diminue les
attributions de l'autorité palestinienne
au profit d'israël et que une partie de
se terrer son territoire et probablement
donné au contrôle d'israël et ce que
l'on peut craindre c'est qu'on assiste à
une tentative d'instauration d'un
bantoustan palestinien
et justement que vont faire les
palestiniens en cas d'accord et ils sont
très affaiblis les palestiniens dont qui
ne sont pas en position très confortable
mais c'est vrai que probablement pour ça
que monsieur trump considère que à
l'usure il peut obtenir un accord en
mettant beaucoup d'argent sur la table
ça dépend aussi de bien entendu de la
réaction des pays de la région de chacun
des pays de la région et il ya tout lieu
de penser qu' ils soutiendront la cause
palestinienne
merci beaucoup claude blanche maison
pour votre analyse merci à vous journée
internationale dédiée à la mémoire des
victimes de l'holocauste il ya 75 ans
jour pour jour l'armée rouge libérer le
camp de concentration et d'extermination
d'auschwitz le premier ministre français
edouard philippe rendu en pologne où il
a déposé une
gerbe sur le mur de la mort lieu où ont
été fusillés des milliers et saunier et
puis à moscou une exposition s'ouvre
aujourd'hui sur ce thème
la correspondance en russie d'antoine
clairon à l'occasion de la soixante
quinzième journée internationale dédiée
à la mémoire des victimes de
l'holocauste le musée juif et centre de
tolérance de moscou présente sa toute
nouvelle exposition intitulée pas le
temps pour l'amour histoire de
survivants de l'holocauste lors de
l'inauguration de cette exposition le
grand rabbin de russie mais aussi les
ambassadeurs en russie de l'allemagne
des etats-unis et d'israël ont tour à
tour pris la parole pour rendre hommage
aux victimes bien entendu mais aussi
pour souligner qu'il était nécessaire de
continuer à combattre l'antisémitisme
encore aujourd'hui l'exposition en
elle-même est composé d'extraits de
journaux intimes de mémoire ou de
biographies publiées ces vingt dernières
années par d'anciens prisonniers des
camps de concentration des combattants
juifs de la résistance ou encore par
leurs enfants ou petits-enfants
l'événement présente aussi des oeuvres
de l'artiste français christian
boltanski du sculpteur polonais miroslaw
balka ou encore des installations
d'artistes contemporains israéliens à
travers ses oeuvres d'art est le récit
de ses onze histoires d'amour des
histoires d'amour qui ont su exister
malgré les immenses difficultés c'est
cette exposition propose ainsi de
nouvelles perspectives pour parler du
traumatisme est du devoir de mémoire et
xenia olco va a été arrêtée avec sa mère
et sa soeur pendant la répression du
soulèvement de varsovie transféré à
auschwitz puis au camp de neuengamme
près de hambourg
elle témoigne aujourd'hui il n'y avait
pas d'eau il n'y avait rien à manger
quand on m'a demandé ce que j'avais
mangé j'ai répondu je ne m'en souviens
pas je ne mange rien
en outre nous avons participé de manière
très active à cette lutte contre les
allemands plus tard les soldats venait
moins souvent parce que nous étions
exposés au score but à la dystrophie on
avait des points et il n'avait rien à
manger ni à boire les gens mouraient et
ont creusé des tombes
sur le terrain les nazis et après
lanternon ont creusé des fausses tout
près de ses thons ont trouvé de l'eau
bien sûr les gens tombaient malades
habitent
on est déjà fin septembre c'est la fin
de l'insurrection de varsovie
ils ont jeté des tracts trois fois et
les gens sortent et le dire il était
écrit dans ses tracts rendez vous sinon
tout varsovie sera réduit en cendres à
ceux qui se rendront nous allons
garantir la vie et une existence normale
[Musique]
l'audio il y à une heure de calme ni les
allemands ni les polonais ne tirait les
gens sortent et il tenait leur foulard
vous voyez les gens marcher dans les
ruines leur foulard à la main cette
situation s'est répétée deux fois au
cours de ces deux mois à la fin du
troisième mois fin septembre ils ont
jeté les tracts pour la dernière fois
rien ay est drôle christophe dépasse les
nyalas
il n'y avait presque personne
nous avions une maison et un jardin
quand les allemands écrit rendez vous
sinon nous allons tous vous détruire et
les identités de 76 mille juifs déportés
ils sont inscrits il s'agit
du mur des noms mémorial de la shoah à
paris un monument fraîchement rénové qui
emmanuel macron a inauguré aujourd'hui
175 membres ayant été rajoutés la visite
du chef de l'elysée intervient en
quelques jours après son déplacement en
israël pour le rassemblement d'une
quarantaine de chefs d'état en hommage
aux victimes de la shoah et pour en
parler nous sommes avec eux anastasio
carabasse guide conférencier au mémorial
de la shoah hauteur de la shoah
l'obsession de l'antisémitisme depuis le
19e siècle aux éditions bréal bonsoir
anastasio carabasse merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france vous avez
assisté je croise ces cérémonies
aujourd'hui avec emmanuel macron qu'est
ce que voudront retiendrez écoutez
c'était très émouvant de voir toutes ces
personnalités qui sont venus au mémorial
c'est un site symbolique qui a un rôle
fondamental aujourd'hui pour notamment
les nouvelles générations pour les
citoyens de demain donc le présent dans
république bien sûr un discours poignant
mais également des députés la maire de
paris et toutes les personnes qui
travaillent mémoire de la shoah au
quotidien c'était important qu'on se
rassemble tous avec notamment les
rescapés ceux qui restent et
malheureusement il ne reste plus
beaucoup de monde et c'est important de
les porter de leur montrer que nous
avons une mission
or on en parlera justement après de ce
devoir de mémoire c'est une
commémoration 75e anniversaire qui a
lieu au moment où on apprend
l'augmentation de 130 % du nombre de
faits racistes et xénophobes en 2019 des
chiffres alarmants concernant également
le caractère antisémite un précisément
puisque beaucoup de juifs tout
simplement ne se sentent pas
en sécurité en france on apprend que
voilà ils ont augmenté de 27% par
rapport à 2018 ces faits antisémites on
se dit dans ces moments là que
l'histoire ne sert pas toujours de leçon
quand l'histoire est bien enseigner je
pense qu'elle peut être un rempart
contre l'antisémitisme je suis également
enseignant d'histoire-géographie
j'ai des lycéens en face de moi tous les
jours et je sais l'importance de
l'enseignement peut-être qu'en france
même si nous sommes considérés comme les
bons élèves de l'europe sur
l'enseignement de la shoah en france il
ya encore un travail à faire la chose
n'est pas une histoire figé c'est pas
quelque chose qui est fermé c'est
quelque chose qui en construction c'est
important aujourd'hui de dire que la
shoah
ce n'est pas quelque chose qui est qui
fait partie juste du passé on a des
enseignements à tirer
nous devons transmettre parce qu'on est
à l'abri de rien il ya en moyenne 800
actes antisémites par an en france pour
une communauté qui représente moins de
1% de la population et il ya un institut
britannique qui a fait un sondage en
décembre 2018 qui dit que 21 % des 18-34
ans n'ont jamais entendu parler de la
shoah
pourtant officiellement on enseigne
l'ajustement j'allais souvent parlé
cette étude et jeu sauf erreur de ma
part cette étude ifop de 2018 dit aussi
qu'un français sur dix j'avais entendu
parler de la shoah et ça s'aggrave avec
les jeunes vous dit on et les bons
élèves de l'europe vous êtes vous mêmes
profs alors comment vous expliquez ça ça
paraît incroyable qu'un français sur dix
on n'est pas entendu parler écouter
l'éducation nationale en france fin
officiellement fait un vrai travail et
je sais que le ministre de l'éducation
nationale s'est vraiment engagé le
président également après il faut voir
le quotidien des enseignants
il ya de très nombreux enseignants je
les ai vécus notamment dans des points
difficiles quand j'ai commencé ma
carrière
nous sommes seuls et donc on nous dit il
faut enseigner la shoah en troisième
officiellement on a quatre heures pour
enseigner la seconde guerre mondiale et
être heures 4 heures la seconde guerre
mondiale points et dans la seconde
guerre mondiale il ya éventuellement la
shoah c'est à dire de 10 minutes à une
heure maximum parce qu'on peut pas
dépasser sinon peut pas comprendre la
seconde guerre mondiale donc ça veut
dire quoi un élève qui finit son collège
il a pas vaguement entendu parler là
choix dans certains établissements ont
fait
un travail en profondeur mais pas
partout surtout dans des coins difficile
on sait que l'enseignement la shoah pose
problème au lycée c'est pareil au lycée
l'enseignement la shoah peut aller
jusqu'à un maximum deux heures les
enseignants sont pris par l'emploi du
temps et par les programmes donc
finalement la choix on l'évoquent certes
mais peut-être pas assez et peut-être
pas en profondeur et d'ailleurs dans les
nouveaux programmes c'est toujours le
cas lacheraf fait partie d'un programme
d'un sujet parmi d'autres et vous parlez
surtout dans les coins difficile on le
sait c'est compliqué je le dis sur dans
la presse les plateaux de télé c'est
très compliqué d'enseigner la shoah dans
dans les banlieues notamment
est ce que pour vous il ya une forme de
résignation
finalement un petit peu de lâcheté on
laisse tomber pour ne pas heurter pour
avoir une forme de paix quel est votre
regard là-dessus je vais pas généraliser
parce que je connais beaucoup de
collègues au mémoire de la shoah nous
nous accueillons beaucoup d'enseignants
d'ailleurs pour les former parce qu'il
faut former les enseignants comment est
ce qu'on enseigne la joie c'est
compliqué qu'est ce que vous voulez dire
aux élèves en 1h06 millions de personnes
exterminées pas tant que ça mais je
parle justement du ministère en eau
quel est alors il tique là dessus
officiellement il ya un vrai fera jamais
bien sûr bien sûr mais malheureusement
et on le voit dans les vingt dernières
années georges bensoussan a parlé des
territoires perdus de la république
malheureusement à un moment donné je
peux pas citer une personne mais un
système a fait qu'on a fermé les yeux et
qu'on a préféré acheter la paix sociale
en disant c'est compliqué d'ailleurs
regardez les programmes les programmes
de terminale premier chapitre d'histoire
nous enseignons doit choisir entre les
mémoires de la seconde guerre mondiale
où les mémoire de la guerre d'algérie
donc ça veut dire quoi oui vous ça veut
dire que dans certains établissements
parlera pas des mémoires la seconde
guerre mondiale parce que c'est plus
facile de parler des morts de la guerre
d'algérie donc c'est au professeur qui
qu'ils aient laissé si j'ose dire de la
lourde responsabilité de choisir en
toute chose y ait là choix et la guerre
d'algérie c'est ça que vous ne jouiez en
termes si comme si la guerre finalement
les comme si les deux guerres étaient
similaires on parle d'une guerre
d'extermination c'est d'actualité avec
emma exactement justement ça sera
l'objet de notre débat à 21h30 qui a
fait ce parallèle on la veut dire que
c'est l'un ou l'autre c'est assez
étonnant ce que vous nous dites oui il
n'y a pas de débat là dessus je veux
dire historiquement parlant on ne peut
pas comparer je ne dis pas que la guerre
d'algérie n'est pas important ça n'a
rien à voir et on parle d'une guerre
d'extermination contre une guerre de
décolonisation ça n'a pas du tout la
même raison qu'il faut choisir leur
alignement entre les deux
voilà les enseignants étant alors qu'il
faudrait peut-être au contraire enseigne
et bien les deux oui pourquoi pas les
deux mais dans ces cas là on fait la
distinction et on ne demande pas aux
enseignants finalement de choisir
on ne peut pas choisir dans ces cas là
aujourd'hui il ya plusieurs solutions
propose également le gouvernement la loi
via contre la n 1 de toute forme de
racisme la résolution maillard qui
touchait plus spécifiquement
l'antisémitisme qui assimile
l'antisionisme à de l'antisémitisme pour
vous c'est aussi les débuts de solutions
pour lutter contre l'antisémitisme où il
vaut mieux effectivement se cantonner à
l'éducation
je pense que tous ces éléments sont
importants pour lutter contre
l'antisémitisme
ils font un ensemble de choses et un
ensemble d'acteurs qui travaillent en
collaboration
c'est l'enseignement mais c'est aussi la
justice il faut un cadre bien sûr avec
des lois moi je sais avec mes élèves que
les réseaux sociaux jouent un rôle
extrêmement important aujourd'hui les
théories du complot c'est dans les
réseaux sociaux que ça marche la loi est
importante mais sans l'enseignement à
côté une une société ne peut pas
fonctionner sans un enseignement solide
et là dessus la france a encore du
travail à faire à mon sens vous parler
évidemment de l'enseignement et du
devoir de mémoire avec les derniers
rescapés
la shoah est ce que vous connaissez
extrêmement bien ce sujet est ce que les
autorités ont prévu la suite justement
pour entretenir ce devoir de mémoire
nous sommes les témoins des témoins les
derniers sont en train de partir les
derniers rescapés et c'est important et
on l'a vu aujourd'hui c'est important de
leur montrer que nous n'allons pas
oublier ce qui s'est passé et que nous
allons transmettre toujours au quotidien
transmettre pourquoi je pas parce que
c'est une obligation on transmet parce
que c'est une obligation je veux dire de
l'éducation nationale on transmet parce
que nous sommes des êtres humains il ya
encore quatre vingt ans on envoyait des
enfants dans les chambres à gaz quelle
société voulons-nous pour demain donc
ces rescapés doivent comprendre que nous
sommes ici pour transmettre et pour
transmettre et que nous n'allons pas
oublier parce que si nous oublions on
risque de refaire les mêmes erreurs et
ça on ne le veut pas nous enseignants et
nous aussi
guide conférencier moral de la chose
aujourd'hui et plus globalement ça sera
ma dernière question est ce que les
autorités du gouvernement était la
hauteur de la situation où on en parle
voilà qu'on qu'il faut en parler puis on
balaye c'est un petit peu après alors si
c'est juste pour faire des
commémorations c'est sûr que bon ça
c'est important on l'a vu aujourd'hui
mais une commémoration ne suffit pas
esquivé à la hauteur je pense que j'ai
pas de réponse à vous donner
mais quoi qu'il en soit c'est important
les discours mais les actes
à mon sens sont encore plus importants
et dans l'éducation nationale
malheureusement ça fait dix ans que je
suis dans l'éducation nationale on a
entendu beaucoup de discours
c'est important qu'il y ait les actes
derrière donc on attend et on espère que
ça va changer
merci beaucoup anastasio caravane
d'avoir été avec nous en direct sur rt
france et donc quelques instants rester
avec nous nous recevons notre invité
politique ce soir virginie joueront
eurodéputé membre du bureau national du
et puis nous parlerons du procès qui
s'ouvre demain entre les anciens
salariés de goodyear et la firme
américaine
après six années de procédure
[Musique]
certains disent que nous ne sommes pas
une chaîne française
d'autres affirment même que nous ne
sommes pas journalistes mais vous
[Musique]
savez-vous vraiment qui nous sommes
les valeurs que nous défendons
la liberté
la liberté d'expression et d'opinion
nous défendons l'égalité l'égalité des
chances pour tous
[Musique]
nous sommes une équipe
nous sommes cette diversité qui fait la
france
et nous en sommes fiers
[Musique]
et si vous veniez voir par vous même
les news ne s'arrête jamais mais c'est
votre soutien que nous apprécions le
plus
[Musique]
à 6 ans il y avait tous ici qu'elle perd
le vertdure de la vie la zone était
habité par plusieurs familles mais
maintenant je vais voir vous même comme
ça sol de 700 à 1000 familles seront
évacués de force aujourd'hui ou demain
quelques unes seront jetés dehors
parfois quand je marche sur le charbon
je vois qu'ils fument par endroits mais
dessus ton pied glisse qu'on lise le
charbon est l'objectif principal
tout le monde veut du charbon les gens
sont traités ici comme des rebuts
[Musique]
le dopage arme politique ou scandale
sportif oui c'est évidemment la scala le
sportif puisque sa fausse toutes les
compétitions et c'est évidemment
contraire à l'idéal olympique
maintenant ça peut être utilisée est
manipulée à des fins politiques c'est
assez compliqué d'arriver à y voir clair
dans cette dans cette affaire puisque
d'un côté on a un ministre des sports et
l'ensemble de l'exécutif russe qui
défend les athlètes et qui nie tout tout
scandale institutionnalisée au niveau du
sport russe alors que de notre côté on a
le chef de la rue stade acquis et lui
met le doigt sur un certain nombre de
dysfonctionnements le ministre et le
gouvernement nous dise pas la même chose
que le chef de l' agence ses premiers
problèmes de gouvernance le deuxième
c'est que le chef de l' agence ne tient
pas sa boutique ne tient pas sa maison
puisqu'il dénonce les pratiques qui
serait une pratique de la vieille garde
qui continueraient à trafiquer comme on
le faisait à l'époque de l'union
soviétique les amériques l'admirent
poutine comme comme assez souvent
d'ailleurs quand une ligne assez
raisonnable il ne dit pas il n'y a pas
eu de dopage il dit il faut punir les
individus
donc c'est aussi un avertissement donné
aux fédération russe de sports et
peut-être à l' agence antidopage russes
pour leur dire faites votre métier
[Musique]
c'est le sentiment que vous avez eue
vous aussi ce besoin d'autonomie
oui complètement vrai besoin d'autonomie
besoin de retourner à des choses plus
essentielles en fait est vraiment de
sentir qu'on n'est pas forcément un
poids pour la planète
il ya une idée derrière il ya une
philosophie aussi qu'on a vu la serre
les plantes qui poussent le fait de
vivre avec les plantes comme ça vraiment
commune comme une machine un organisme
et pour faire partie de cet organisme
on a eu vraiment l'impression de se
construire en même temps qu'on
reconstruisait cette maison en faisant
toutes ces rencontres mais je pense que
ces gens de projets qui se fait pas tout
seul dans son coin on est dans un truc
vraiment de coopération de partage de
partage
[Musique]
20h30 heure française merci ne rejoint
en direct sur rt france 56e jours de
contestation contre la réforme des
retraites à 48 heures d'une nouvelle
mobilisation nationale à l'appel de
l'intersyndicale ce sont les avocats qui
se font entendre aujourd'hui encore
l'assemblée générale du barreau de seine
saint denis a voté cet après midi à
bobigny la poursuite de la grève
le conseil national des barreaux appel
de son côté toutes les robes noires à
participer à une manifestation nationale
à paris lundi prochain à écouter leurs
revendications
la revendication principale elle est
évidemment le retrait du projet de
retraite
actuellement à l'examen
au gouvernement déposé par le
gouvernement et l'examen à l'assemblée
nationale et
plus généralement ce problème de
retraite
la face immergée de l'iceberg
on se rend compte que en réalité un
véritable problème en france avec la
justice de ce pays
une justice qui manque de moyens une
justice qui ne peut pas travailler
convenablement et on le voit bien
puisque aujourd'hui lorsque avocats sont
en grève dans trois semaines comme c'est
le cas on entame la quatrième semaine
les tribunaux s'engorge
les audiences
surcharge on a fait rare des mois de
février et mars pour être très remplie
et donc la justice ne fonctionne pas et
en fait nous ce qu'on voudrait essayer
de faire comprendre c'est qu'au delà du
combat des avocats contre le projet de
réforme est un véritable combat glos
plus globale sur l'état de la justice en
france est
et les moyens qui sont donnés dans ce
pays à la justice pour travailler et aux
avocats qui travaillent et la réforme
des retraites au coeur d'une conférence
ce matin entre syndicats et retraités
présents une dizaine de membres de
différentes associations syndicales
écouter certains participent aux
participants au micro d'rtl france nos
revendications et bien c'est
dard été arrêtés entre là je parle en
tant que retraité d'arrêter et puis de
nous expliquer exactement quelle en est
la loi car quand on lit les articles on
a beau lire lire plusieurs fois
eh bien on a du mal à les comprendre et
puis on voit en eux mêmes
le gouvernement demande aux syndicats de
trouver du financement donc est-ce
qu'ils ont pas trouvé d'autres
financements
on voit le conseil d'état aussi qui se
pose des questions on voit vent et donc
c'est pas très clair franchement pas
très clair très opaque et donc il vaut
mieux prendre un peu de souffle et puis
réfléchir à peu plus sur le long terme a
diminué de 25% à 30%
les revenus des retraités même si on
tape sur les plus riches
ça veut dire quand même un
appauvrissement général de 16 millions
de personnes bientôt 17 bientôt 18 et
que ce point de vue là c'est quand même
un impact considérable pour la société
je pense qu'on n'a pas encore bien
réaliser que ce n'est pas un changement
technique
c'est en fait un changement de société
et que cette société là ça n'a plus rien
à voir avec celle que nous avons connue
construite en 1945 avec un système
parfait destiné à redonner aux retraités
qui était à l'époque
très bien très pénalisés de redonner un
niveau de vie à peu près équivalent à
celui des selleries et pour décrypter
l'actualité nous sommes avec virginie et
joro député et membre du bureau national
du rnc notre invité politique ce soir
bonsoir virginie un jours merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur arte france on a
dit cinquante sixième jour de
mobilisation contre la réforme des
retraites qui semble quand même suivre
son cours du côté du gouvernement
quelle est votre réaction là dessus
y a pas plus tard que vendredi j'étais
au voeu du procureur de tgi de
strasbourg et en même temps qu'ils
avaient ce beau discours il y avait donc
effectivement une manifestation des
avocats du barreau du bas rhin qui est
manifesté leur mécontentement mais je
partage ce sentiment et je pense que ce
sens ce sentiment est partagé par un
grand nombre de français parce que on le
voit au fur et à mesure de l'avancée de
cette réforme s'aperçoit que c'est du
flou elissa devient de plus en plus
illisible j'entendais cet immense et
scintillante iccat et c'est vrai
aujourd'hui on ne sait pas où on voit on
va on s'aperçoit que le gouvernement le
11 décembre dans la nuit ils décident à
une certaine génération 75-73 adana
minutes il décide de mettre en place
cette réforme pour cette génération on
voit que selon les manifestations de
certaines corporatisme il arrive à faire
reculer le gouvernement
donc on se retrouve dans une situation
de flou et aujourd'hui les français qui
cotisent tous les mois qui ont du mal à
boucler leurs fins de mois ne n'arrive
pas à se projeter dans l'avenir et le
signal fort en plus très récemment avec
l'avis du conseil d'état
finalement démontre que nous avions
raison que nous dénoncions effectivement
ce trait forme qui a été mise en place à
la va vite dans un coin qu'on nous qu'on
nous vend depuis des mois sous prétexte
qu'un déficit mais j'ai entendu et avec
attention
la vie de cet économiste le jura vaud
qui disait que si on veut qu'il y avait
des fonds qui a pas de problème de
déficit si on arrivait à chercher
effectivement les fonds là où il était
notamment avec ses 24 milliards d'euros
que l'on pourrait récupérer après 2025
concernant le remboursement de l'âge de
la dette sociale alors ça c'est vrai que
les avis divergent en fonction des
économistes certains estiment qu'il y a
besoin de cette réforme d'autres non une
chose est sûre on vous l'avait évoqué la
vie très critique du conseil d'état
alors on entend des voix là il faut
aussi le modéré en disant c'est vrai
qu'il donne du grain à moudre à tous les
camps si j'ose dire mais tout de même on
voit que le conseil d'état la très haute
juridiction pointe beaucoup beaucoup de
difficulté à laquelle va se confronter
le gouvernement il met en garde ce
gouvernement contre justement le flou
autour de cette réforme des retraites
est-ce que selon vous où emmanuel macron
doit clairement à la lumière de cette
dernière éléments reculer bien sûr il
doit reculer
et puis même dès le départ on avait un
avis du corps le conseil d'orientation
de la retraite jeu honnêtement qui peut
dire que c'est raisonnable de dire qu'
un déficit entre 7 milliards et 10 17
milliards déjà on a un delta de 10
milliards ce n'est pas sérieux
je pense que cet avis et 100 et je pense
que le gouvernement doit prendre en
considération cet avis mais aussi les 60
plus de 60% de français sont contre
cette réforme
à un moment donné il faut entendre la
politique ça sert à ça c'est aussi
d'être pragmatique on a une sorte des
chiffres qui sont pas sérieux et
aujourd'hui il doit effectivement
prendre en compte cette grogne des
français qui en plus vivre dans
l'insécurité permanente
c'est inacceptable j'essaie de me placer
de l'autre côté
évidemment je suis là pour ça pour vous
attention à la contradiction emmanuel
macron a quand même été élu
démocratiquement
il avait dit qu'il ferait cette retraite
il n'avait il a dit qu'il ne toucherait
pas à l'âge mais qui ferait la retraite
à points aujourd'hui certainement que
lui se dit je suis légitime à la mener à
bout qu'est-ce que vous pouvez lui
répondre et effectivement il ya 60% de
français qui sont rouges
mais ces français ont aussi élu emmanuel
macron peut-être pas 60% mais le système
aujourd'hui fait qu'il a été élu
président de la république
comme vous l'avez souligné ce n'était
pas dans son programme il avait bien
certifié qu'il ne toucherait pas à l'âge
légal de la retraite
aujourd'hui on se rend compte qu'on a un
package qui est floue on ne sait pas
finalement quel est l'âge pivot on ne
sait pas ce qu'il ya dedans on ne sait
pas quelle est la valeur du point
aujourd'hui sont incapables de nous de
nous donner une calculatrice pour
simuler notre retraite donc devant cet
amateurisme et aussi par un pardon mais
l'élection d' emmanuel macron a
effectivement et la gagner mais c'était
pas pour mais c'était contre contre
effectivement notre mouvement mais
c'était pas pour moi ça s'est passé pour
d'autres avant lui est ce qu'on doit
changer tout simplement à notre système
électoral vème république finalement ça
c'est une c'est à étudier je pense qu'au
delà du choix électoral je pense que
même au niveau de la réforme des
retraites on sait très bien que ce
nouveau mouvement vers la réforme c'est
parce qu'il est allé choisir chercher sa
feuille de route à bruxelles
boxer à l'éclair ça fait des années
qu'elle dit qu'il faut réformer et comme
c'est un bon élève de bruxelles
il nous a donc pondu cette réforme des
retraites qui est très injuste et qui va
vraiment vers l'appauvrissement du
du pouvoir d'achat de nos concitoyens
alors des bonnes nouvelles quand même
sur le front de l'économie aujourd'hui
le chômage qui a baissé de 3 3% en 2010
neuf en france qui semble toucher toutes
les catégories est ce qu'on peut
l'imputer au moins en partie à emmanuel
macron alors moi je me méfie des
chiffres c'est vrai qu'ils viennent de
sortir faudra voir exactement ce qu'elle
dedans est ce que le chômage de longue
durée ont fait partie je ne crois pas
effectivement il eu pas mal de levier
qui font un peu baisser le taux du
chômage c'est qu'il ya eu des plans de
formation que c'est un mouvement
effectivement qui permet de faire
baisser le taux de chômage mais derrière
ces annonces il faut quand même étudier
ces chiffres parce qu'ils sont quand
même où on à 8,6 pour cent de taux de
chômage
je prends pour comparaison l'angleterre
ou l'allemagne ils sont à quoi 2%
autre actualité vous avez parlé de
bruxelles ça nous conduit directement au
break site semaine historique pour le
royaume uni qui va se séparer du reste
de l'europe
bientôt la dont le 31 janvier quelle est
votre réaction demain vous allez devoir
vous même un voter ratifié donc c'est
cet accord tout à fait aller voter pour
bien sûr ce n'est pas une surprise nous
avons effectivement soutenu cette
démarche toute façon c'est une démarche
démocratique à la base on ne peut pas
aller contre la volonté du peuple en
plus en plus à côté de ça cela va nous
permettre aussi de gagner 3,3 deux
eurodéputés nous allons passer de la 5e
place à la 4ème place nous allons avoir
donc plus de deux comédiens d'activités
aussi de poids au niveau du parlement
parce qu'on veut être avant les verts
c'est assez important et sista souligné
on va être le quatrième plus grand
groupe au sein du parlement européen
et puis après voilà c'est à que cet
accord va être va être votée puis
ensuite y aura des négociations parce
que là aussi ça pas être simple et il
faudra suivre effectivement ce dossier
de près justement michel barnier l'a
précisé qu'il présenterait lundi un
projet de mandat de négociation aux
états membres qu'est-ce que vous
vous aimeriez y voir du côté de rennes
pour l'instant on attend de voir ce que
veut monsieur boris johnson puisque ce
n'est pas clair il va faire son discours
mois de février savoir quel type
d'accord commercial
il veut mettre en place et en fonction
de ce choix nous verrons nous si c'est
toujours dans l'intérêt des français ou
pas puisque c'est ça notre boussole
d'ailleurs michel barnier on sent qu'à
de la fébrilité quand même qui met en
garde contre une rupture brutale des
échanges à ce qu'on peut le craindre
parce que beaucoup de secteurs quand
même le craignent savez c'est comme au
poker il ya beaucoup de bluff si on est
dans une phase de négociation donc dans
ces négociations il va y avoir des jeux
de cartes des bluffs dd com comme toi et
avec nous avec les gafsa où
effectivement vous avez vu les
négociations ont fait peur et après on
revient sur des à quoi donc on est en
fait dans une phase de négociations donc
tout est possible tout est permis
ce qu'il faudra trouver à la fin c'est
un équilibre est toujours toujours notre
objectif c'est l'intérêt des français
boris johnson lui en tout cas voit bien
l'intérêt des britanniques
le deal beurre l'argent du beurre la
crémière johnson des droits de douane
sur les voitures allemandes et les
fromages pensais ça ferait très mal ça
veut dire justement qui a ce côté beurre
et l'argent du beurre
l'union européenne risquent de sortir
quand même perdante de ce divorce il ya
ce risque de grêle c'est là qu'on va
voir de l'utilité de l'union européenne
c'est là qu'on va voir si vraiment elle
et elle sert à quelque chose
c'est là qu'on va voir si elle a du
poids et c'est à ce moment là qu'on
verra si nous français on arrive à tirer
notre épingle du jeu dans l'actualité
également
évidemment les 75e anniversaire de la
libération du camp d'auschwitz avec les
diverses commémorations voulez vous
faire réagir ce sera l'objet de notre
débat tout à l'heure déjà ce parallèle
qui a fait bondir du côté des rendus et
rennes mais aussi de de la droite plus
traditionnelle l'est républicain le
parallèle entre shoah et colonisation
algérienne pour emmanuel macron quelle
est votre réaction
je souhaite c'est inadmissible et c il
est déjà en campagne électorale
voilà il joue sur tous les tableaux il
attise la haine il
il est dans la division et ce n'est pas
la hauteur d'un chef d'état il faut
laisser la mémoire et la shoah telle
qu'elle est
il faut pas mettre ça sur le même pied
d'égalité on peut très bien s'adresser à
tous nos concitoyens sans faire de la
surenchère et je trouve que vraiment
c'est pas la hauteur d'un chef d'état
pour vous il ya aucune sincérité quand
il nous parle de ça parce que là on
avait parlé également un crime contre
l'humanité pendant sa campagne avait
déjà bondi resserrement des manoeuvres
électorales pour vous pour moi c'est
effectivement des manoeuvres électorales
aujourd'hui comme vous le savez il en
difficulté on a encore vu le dernier
sondage ça ne fait que baisser
d'ailleurs depuis qu'il est président ça
baisse je me demande jusqu'où on va
aller parce que ça ne fait que baisser
je pense comme il l'a dit il est en
campagne électorale donc il faut qu'ils
séduisent un électorat est ce que vous
l'avez dit l'a dit pendant les élections
présidentielles et là ils leur sort
maintenant donc clairement il se sert de
ces événements tragiques pour lui et
pour faire sa campagne
aujourd'hui à une augmentation de 130 %
du nombre de faits racistes et
xénophobes en france en 2010 9
augmentation également spécifiquement de
l'antisémitisme 27% par rapport à 2018
est ce qu'on prend le problème dans le
du côté de du bon côté en france pour
lutter contre ce fléau
déjà il faut regarder ce qu'il ya dedans
c'est vrai que
les premiers persécutés en france enfin
si on peut dire comme les victimes sont
quand même les actes anti chrétiens
ensuite c'est vrai que ce sont les actes
antisémites et à la fin donc les actes
anti musulmans je pense qu'on est dans
un dans un climat qui est comme gelée
dit de division où on attise la haine ou
malgré la lutte parce qu'il ya quand
même des associations il ya des épaules
qui font que il ya c'est un sujet qui
revient tout le temps mais manifestement
n'y a pas les moyens je prends juste les
cas le cas de d'humeur de madame halimi
honnêtement c'est quoi cette décision
qu'elle signale on donne ci parce que
sous prétexte on fume du cannabis
on ne peut pas être traduit en justice
les juges ont appelé emmanuel macron sur
ce point à respecter leur indépendance
soit c'est une bien sûr liaision vue
mais peut-être une décision judiciaire
mais elle n'est pas moral à mon sens
quel signal on donne aux jeunes quand on
y est busan ça sera ma dernière question
on nous dit marine le pen n'est pas la
bienvenue pour parler du nazisme et que
j'ai envie de lui répondre mais madame
busin on vous entend pas sur la gestion
du coroner virus et puis pareil à l'est
aussi en campagne ils nous font ils
veulent faire peur aux gens toujours
nous ramener à cette époque
moi je trouve que c'est une insulte moi
mon grand père est un il a eu la
médaille des évadés et je pense qu'une
grande partie de notre électorat pareil
a eu des parents des grands parents qui
ont été résistants je l'invite à
regarder aussi dans notre mouvement
beaucoup de personnalités ont été des
résistants je pense à mes yeux devaient
zad monsieur de camaret donc là aussi on
est dans la surenchère électorale où il
faut nous insulter pour exister
merci beaucoup virginie genre au député
membre du bureau national du
rassemblement national d'avoir été avec
nous toujours en france et demain que
débute le procès des ex salariés de
goodyear après des années de luttes ces
derniers restent déterminés un point
final à des
année d'audience et de manifestations le
point avec mona amont dès lors le 14
janvier 2014 l'usiné de pneumatiques
goodyear d'amiens-nord fermé laissant
sur le carreau plus de 1100 43 salariés
six ans plus tard la bataille judiciaire
est loin d'être terminée le 28 janvier
843 ex goodyear ont rendez vous devant
le conseil de prud'hommes
les plaignants contestent le caractère
économique de leur licenciement
c'est le plus gros procès aux
prud'hommes de france si l'on a pris en
oubliant les plaies sont toujours les
mêmes ouverte béante à vif une fermeture
des usines c'est pour celles et ceux qui
la subissent une violence absolue
surtout quand il n'y a absolument aucune
justification économique et que
l'acharnement du groupe à détruire le
personnel a laissé des traces à tout
jamais ce dossier est devenu au fil du
temps de plus en plus sensibles car
l'usiné devenue un symbole politique et
sociale c'est en effet sur ce site que
françois hollande alors en campagne
s'était rendu en octobre 2011 pour
défendre les licenciements boursiers une
promesse de campagne qui ne s'est jamais
concrétisée alors les années passent
mais la lutte continue pour les
ex-salariés actions coup de poing
manifestations rassemblements ou encore
interview télévisée quelques années plus
tard en 2016 sur rmc emmanuel macron
alors ministre de l'économie deux
françois hollande s'était confronté à
mickaël wamen ex leader de la cgt de
goodyear amiens nord et entend dire que
les changes était des plus tendues ça
n'existe pas d'interdire du licenciement
ou alors vous vivez dans une économie
fermée administrés ça n'est pas
l'économie française passe un nombre de
plaignants le conseil des prud'hommes
d'amiens a été obligé de déplacer
l'audience dans le zénith de la ville
nous allons démontrer que nous avons été
victimes d'une stratégie de
délocalisation purement financière la
justice est longue très longue trop
longue mais nous ne lâcherons jamais et
nous obtiendrons le jugement qui viendra
nous dire qu'il n'ya jamais eu de
justification économique pour nos
licenciements
rappelons qu'en octobre 2018 les
conseillers prud'homaux damien n'avait
pas pu se mettre d'accord sur les
demandes des ex-salariés de goody
qui réclamé réparation du préjudice subi
pour leur licenciement
c'est donc un juge départiteur un
magistrat professionnel qui devra rendre
le verdict à l'issue de cette nouvelle
audience
et pour en parler nous sommes avec à
gabriel colletis président de
l'association du manifeste pour
l'industrie bon soit gabriel colletis
merci d'être avec nous en direct sur
arte france six ans après le procès
lancé la bataille un de ses ex salariés
face à la firme américaine un procès
fleuve selon vous quelles sont vos
attentes
écoutez en effet je crois que c'est un
procès qui est un procès symbolique
je rappelle que si goodyear a été en
effet touché par par ces fermetures de
sites
l'ensemble des producteurs de pneus en
france je pense également à dalle hop je
prends ça à continental a vu ses usines
fermées donc le cas vous dire est
symbolique mais en même temps
représentatif d'une des stratégies qui
est mise en oeuvre par des entreprises
dont la finalité n'est probablement pas
de produire des pneus ou d'augmenter la
valeur ajoutée mais en effet de réaliser
les profits les plus importants possible
donc quand une ixième coûte trop cher
quand le coût du travail est trop élevé
eh bien on ferme en effet cette
entreprise cette cuisine et on
délocalise la production mais ici on
voit bien que la finalité de
l'entreprise est orienté vers la
réalisation de dividende de profit le
plus élevé possible et pas vers d autres
d'autres objectifs comme par exemple
augmenter la production avoir des parts
de marché plus importante
verser les salaires élevés maintenir
l'emploi des objectifs apparaissent
comme étant secondaire l'objectif
principal est bien de réaliser profil
plus élevé possible avec donc des marges
élevées pour verser des dividendes aux
actionnaires
mais aujourd'hui
qu'est ce que vous espérez obtenir de la
justice et porte sur la nature de
l'entreprise
voici un plaisant et les finalités que
les entreprises doivent aujourd'hui
réalisées est ce que ces entreprises
dont uniquement des moments dire des
actifs liquides dont la finalité est de
produire du cash de produire des profits
pour la satisfaction exclusif des
actionnaires
ou bien est ce que ces entreprises ont
également d'autres finalités
est ce que la loi pacte qui a été votée
récemment en france par le par le
parlement me dis c'est que bien sûr une
entreprise existe doit faire des
bénéfices et il est normal que les
détenteurs de son capital de reçoive une
juste rémunération
mais en même temps la finalité
d'entreprise peut être aussi de produire
des biens des services de qualité doit
également maintenir l'emploi et prendre
en compte ce que la loi pacte désigne
comme étant des enjeux sociaux et
environnementaux
donc c'est véritablement une
interrogation général sur la raison
d'être des entreprises sur l'or sur leur
mission est ce que cette question est
donc limitative aux seuls actionnaires
ou bien une mission plus large sociétale
et environnementale
effectivement qu'elle parlait peut-être
plus de philosophie de voilà de
politique économique
le site effectivement été rasés
aujourd'hui on est davantage dans le
symbole dans la reconnaissance que
finalement dans la réparation d'un
préjudice concret oui vous avez raison
mais c'est pas une question purement
philosophique c'est une question très
très pratique
à quoi servent les entreprises est ce
que les entreprises et bien comme jeudi
10 ans ont comme seule finalité de faire
des profits ou bien est ce que l'on
considère que puisque la la société
entière en quelque sorte est orientée
vers les entreprises sans leur confère
une légitimité très forte
je suis universités moi-même en forme
des étudiants pour qu'ils puissent plus
tard travailler dans les entreprises
donc la société s'organise autour des
entreprises à partir de
où la société entière s'organise autour
des entreprises il est normal que les
entreprises assument une responsabilité
autre que simplement faire des profits
verser des dividendes aux actionnaires
donc c'est pas uniquement qui sont
symboles d'hier c'est une question très
les opérationnels quand on part deux
parties prenantes
est-ce que la seule partie prenante ce
sont les détenteurs du capital
ou bien est ce que les parties prenantes
sont les salariés les fournisseurs les
clients la collectivité territoriale sur
laquelle finalement l'entreprise est
implantée
donc on voit bien que la le détail n'est
pas uniquement philosophique ou
théoriques c'est un débat qui est
extrêmement pratique est le cas de vous
dire est absolument illustratif que
j'aurais peut-être ajouter aussi que les
salariés de vous dire qu'on les salariés
de beaucoup d'entreprises françaises ont
fait des efforts très importants dans le
domaine du pneu de nombreux accords de
compétitivité comme on les appelait à
l'époque car il existe toujours ont été
signés mais des salariés de goodyear
dunlop
on compte accepter un blocage leur
salaire ils ont ils ont accepté le
travail de nuit qui est un travail
évidemment qui est plus pénible
en échange de quoi et bien des emplois
devaient être maintenus et des sites
devaient être maintenus est ce que l'on
voit aujourd'hui c'est que très souvent
mais ces accords de compétitivité qui
ont été arrêtés signés n'ont pas été
respectées or par les parts des
actionnaires n'ont pas été respectées
par les conseils d'administration qui
n'ont pas hésité à fermer les unités de
production les entreprises même
justement vous dites ces salariés ont
fait beaucoup d'efforts aujourd'hui dans
quel état d'esprit il aborde ce procès
je crois qu'ils abordent ce procès avec
une certaine amertume avec le sentiment
sans doute d'avoir été floués d'avoir
fait des efforts très importants qui ne
sont pas qui ne sont pas reconnus mais
ce qui m'inquiète c'est derrière cela
est bien la poursuite du mouvement de
désindustrialisation en
ans de fait qu'aujourd'hui eh bien on
est saisi pas suffisamment en tout cas
un certain nombre de nos portes unités
pour développer une autre industrie en
france parce que pour développer
l'industrie en france et bien on ne
pourra pas le faire uniquement en
baissant les coûts en baissant les
salaires ou en les bloquant ou en
diminuant ce qu'on appelle des charges
mais qui sont en fait des cotisations
sociales
aujourd'hui on a besoin d'une autre
industrie on a besoin d'une autre
compétitivité et je pense que la
compétitivité d'aujourd'hui et de demain
c'est beaucoup plus une compétitivité
écologique que ce n'est une
compétitivité basée uniquement sur sur
une concurrence par les coûts par les
prix par les salaires tel concurrent
cela est néfaste pour l'industrie pour
l'emploi en france
merci beaucoup à gabriella colletti ce
président de l'association du manifeste
pour l'industrie et dans quelques
instants nous reviendrons sur le plan de
paix de donald trump au proche orient
qui sera dévoilé demain en fin d'après
midi
et puis nous parlerons du break site
semaine historique pour le royaume uni
qui sortira de l'union européenne
vendredi à ctv
[Musique]
le dopage arme politique ou scandale
sportif oui c'est évidemment la scala le
sportif puisque sa fausse toutes les
compétitions et c'est évidemment
contraire à l'idéal olympique
maintenant ça peut être utilisée est
manipulée à des fins politiques c'est
assez compliqué d'arriver à y voir clair
dans cette dans cette affaire puisque
d'un côté on a un ministre des sports et
l'ensemble de l'exécutif russe ans qui
défend les athlètes et qui nie tout tout
scandale institutionnalisée au niveau du
sport russe alors que de notre côté on a
le chef de la rue stade acquis et lui
met le doigt sur un certain nombre de
dysfonctionnements le ministre et le
gouvernement nous dise pas la même chose
que le chef de l' agence ses premiers
problèmes de gouvernance le deuxième
c'est que le chef de l' agence ne tient
pas sa boutique ne tient pas sa maison
puisqu'il dénonce les pratiques qui
serait une pratique de la vieille garde
qui continueraient à trafiquer comme on
le faisait à l'époque de l'union
soviétique les amériques je les admire
poutine comme comme assez souvent
d'ailleurs quand une ligne assez
raisonnable il ne dit pas il n'y a pas
eu de dopage il dit il faut punir les
individus
donc c'est aussi un avertissement donné
aux fédération russe de sports et
peut-être à l'agencé antidopage russes
pour leur dire faites votre métier
[Musique]
c'est chacun pour soi dieu pour tous tes
tiacoh politique n'a jamais été obligé
de dire la vérité d idée courageuse des
mots qui comptent la haine en soi vient
de l'ignorance
aujourd'hui on a une gauche l'extrême
tous les témoins de notre époque sont
dans la grande interview
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
[Musique]
je suis sur la voie de gandhi j'essaie
de le copier et même une mauvaise copie
comme war a de la valeur je ne suis pas
là pour faire de quiconque un disciple
de gandhi je suis là pour trouver le
futur j'en dis
oh
assiettes que nous il n'est pas
seulement utilisée pour filer c'est
aussi l'essence même des idées de gandhi
c'est la philosophie indienne
non
des plaques ce que vous voyez autour du
rio est le reflet de ce qui se passe à
l'intérieur de rue c'est gandhi c'est ce
que j'ai compris après de nombreuses
années de travail
[Musique]
lancé ce mouvement de liberté nous a
ouvert cette voie
[Musique]
pour nous il est une incarnation de dieu
c'est pourquoi je le prie
je suis la seule personne encore en vie
qui travaillaient avec gandhi et qui
connaissait comme
10 à 10 d'abord ils signeront ensuite
ils se moqueront de toi et enfin être
rejoindront
[Musique]
pourquoi vraiment hollywood est née au
nigeria et pas par exemple au sénégal au
mali
tout le monde est un homme d'affaires
ont déjà réagi en homme comme femme tout
le monde et businessman et ça c'est
impressionnant
donc nollywood et que là clairement le
vent en poupe et les budgets ce qui est
gros budgets des films à gros budget
comme aux états unis ou même en france
d'ailleurs
aujourd'hui le record de budget aux
nigériens ses 9 millions de dollars et
une montée en gamme
d'un point de vue technique au niveau
des histoires racontées et s'est du coup
ça implique effectivement des budgets
beaucoup plus important donc il ya
beaucoup de choses qui se passent
beaucoup de pays en afrique francophone
notamment qui regarde puisque au nigeria
qui est qui et apprennent et qui
essayent de
de faire pareil
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous merci de nous rejoindre
pour cette deuxième heure d'émission
tout de suite voici les titres de
l'actualité de ce lundi historique pour
israël contestée par les palestiniens
donald trump dévoilera demain à 18
heures son plan de paix pour le
moyen-orient qui selon lui a une chance
d'aboutir
un texte qui divise alors que benyamin
nétanyahou et benny gantz ont reçu
respectivement aujourd'hui à la maison
blanche semaine historique pour le
royaume uni j - 4 avant le break site
la séparation aura lieu vendredi entre
londres et bruxelles en visite à dublin
le négociateur en chef de l'union
européenne michel barnier mettant en
garde contre une rupture brutale
c'était à son retour d'israël dans
l'avion la semaine dernière le président
mettront provoque l'ire de la droite et
l'extrême droite en faisant le parallèle
entre guerre d'algérie et chaud à une
comparaison afin d'afficher sa volonté
de mettre un terme au conflit mémorielle
en france sur la question de la guerre
d'algérie un exercice de relecture de
l'histoire auquel le chef de l'état
devrait procéder au nom de l'état quitte
à emporter peut-être certains ce sera
l'objet de notre face à face ce soir
[Musique]
donald trump s'exprimera donc demain à
18 heures heure de paris au centre du
discours du président américain
son plan de paix pour le moyen-orient le
locataire de la maison blanche reçoit le
premier ministre benyamin netanyahou et
son rival benny gantz
bien que pas encore dévoilé le texte est
déjà jugé historique par l'état hébreu
donald trump et réaffirme aujourd'hui
son amitié pour israël alors que
l'autorité palestinienne menace de se
retirer des accords d'oslo
cet accord ne se base pas sur le droit
international et les lois
internationales
il donne également israël tous ceux qui
le souhaitent aux dépens des droits
nationaux du peuple palestinien qui
s'incarnait dans un état souverain et
indépendant avec jérusalem pour capitale
et le droit au retour des réfugiés
ce texte ne constitue pas une base pour
une solution rapide
il vient d'une partie qui a perdu toute
crédibilité en tant que médiatrice dans
le cadre d'un processus politique
sérieux et authentique
c'est un honneur de recevoir le premier
ministre netanyahu en deux les grands
amis est un des grands amis de notre
pays cela fait presque trois ans que
nous avons une relation extraordinaire
et cela fait longtemps que je vous
connais ça fait maintenant trois en deux
temps forts et nous avons fait beaucoup
par israël
il me semble que la relation n'a jamais
été aussi bonne nous allons discuter de
la paix au moyen-orient américaine
rachetée d'ores et déjà pas gaza
plusieurs centaines de palestiniens
manifestent aujourd'hui pour afficher
leur rejet de ce plan de paix de donald
trump ce dernier ici représentée en
mannequin morand drapeaux américains et
israéliens et militants millefeuille son
effigie depuis son arrivée à la
blanche le président américain affirme
vouloir résoudre le conflit israélo
palestinien tout en affichant son
soutien à l'état hébreu
michael ce qu'ils devaient aller avec
clément hospital
c'est une initiative qu'ils préparent
depuis trois ans un plan de paix pour
mettre fin à 72 ans de conflit entre
israéliens et palestiniens
le deal du siècle concocté par donald
trump devrait être rendu public d'ici
mardi
pour l'occasion benyamin netanyahou et
son rival benny gantz ont été conviés à
washington par le vice-président
américain mike pence
les etats unis se réjouissent
d'accueillir le premier ministre
benyamin netanyahu le dirigeant du parti
bleu blanc benny gantz à la maison
blanche la semaine prochaine les rumeurs
sur les détails et le calendrier de
notre plan de paix secrets sont purement
spéculatives si les détails restent
encore tenu secret une enveloppe de 50
milliards de dollars d'investissements
internationaux dans les territoires
palestiniens les pays arabes voisins a
été inscrit dans le projet d'accord
historique pour le premier ministre
israélien sous une telle opportunité ne
se présente qu'une fois dans l'histoire
et ne peut pas être manquée aujourd'hui
nous avons à la maison blanche que sur
une grand ami qu'israël ait jamais eu
nous avons la plus grande opportunité
que nous n'ayons jamais pendant trois
ans j'ai parlé avec le président
entraîneur et son équipe de nos besoins
nationaux et de sécurité les plus vitaux
qui doivent tel un cru dans tout
arrangement diplomatique
j'ai trouvé à la maison blanche une
oreille attentive à ses besoins je suis
donc plein d'espoir a fait quoi
nous sommes à l'aube d'un moment
historique dans les annales de notre
état je pars pour washington avec un
sentiment de grande mission de grandes
responsabilités et des grandes
opportunités
ceux qui ne se reproduira pas pour
assurer l'avenir d'israël n'enthousiasme
loin d'être partagé par les palestiniens
l'accord du siècle est déjà mort a fait
savoir le président de l'autorité
palestinienne mahmoud abbas lors de sa
rencontre avec vladimir poutine la
semaine dernière
ce ne serait pas la première fois qu'une
initiative américaine échoue dans cet
épineux dossier
en 1993 la poignée de main historique
entre isaac rabin et yasser arafat dans
les jardins de la maison blanche avait
abouti à une nouvelle insurrection
palestinienne la seconde intifada
scénario redouté aujourd'hui par
certains analystes
au lieu de résoudre le conflit israélo
palestinien l'initiative de donald trump
nous leurs animaux et pour en parler
nous sommes en direct depuis jérusalem
avec micha et steyn correspondant de la
chaîne de télévision publique
israélienne cannes c'est notre rubrique
vu de l'extérieur ce soir bonsoir à
mischa estinnes merci d'être avec nous
en direct sur rt france très critiquée
revient de le dire du côté palestinien
comment est perçu ce plan américain du
côté d'israël tout à l'heure nous ne
connaissons pas encore exactement les
détails du plan mais parlera d'une
annexion 40 % de la cisjordanie
toutes les colonies israéliennes se
seront tombons sur la coupe d'israël et
le reste de la cisjordanie ce sera un
état palestinien
l'icd de monsieur netanyahu les autres
grands partis tels que par exemple parti
bleu blanc de plaintes disent qu'il
s'agit du meilleur plan qu'israël est
jamais vu car ce n'est pas basée sur la
frontière de 65 ans et le besoin
d'occuper des colonies village de francs
être vidés de leurs habitants mais la
plupart resteront sous le contrôle et
sera donc c'est un très bon accord pour
les israéliens alors un très bon accord
pour l'existant et lien
beaucoup moins pour les palestiniens
comme comment peut-on imaginer si
effectivement ces termes sont ceux de
l'accord que les palestiniens acceptent
de 25 coups de tonnerre a déclaré
aujourd'hui ben sera possible qu'avec
l'accord des palestiniens
que se passera-t-il si et les
palestiniens refusent le gouvernement
israélien pourra-t-il annexer des zones
sans l'accord palestiniens c'est une
autre question
mais au cours des journées passées
depuis l'annnonce du gland voit que les
palestiniens disent 'nous n'acceptons
pas cet accord il évoque des
manifestations l'âge des mesures contre
les états unis
il y aura une réunion de l'autorité
palestinienne demain pour essayer de
trouver une solution
comment agir après ce plan qui sera
annoncée demain fait accompli notons le
moment c'est un grand nom de la part des
palestiniens et ce qui est intéressant
c'est que le hamas et le jihad
ces partis sont du même avis il refuse
d'accepter un accord qui n'est pas
fondée sur la côtière 276 d'accepter un
plan qui va retirer l'air de new york
la grande question c'est comment les
pays arabes
at il agi à petit aux annonces du vin
blanc la jordanie par exemple qui a de
très grands intérêts dans la région ou
l'egypte par exemple
mais pour le main c'est très clair les
palestiniens refusent cet accord est ce
que selon vous il pourrait y avoir un
risque d'embrasement à nouveau vous dit
comment vont ils réagir est ce que ça
peut mal se passer
remettre de l'huile sur le feu côté
israélien on renforce sa vigilance
ils ne recrutent pas de nouveaux soldats
en prévision de nouvelles manifestations
ou une nouvelle riposte du côté
palestinien
mais tous les israéliens se préparent et
d'étudier les réactions
il faut utile de savoir que c'est une
chose de dire nous sommes d'accord avec
ce plan est une autre de dire nous
allons appliquer ce point après l'avion
-située appelant les gouvernements
pourrait l'accepter mais c'est une étape
jusqu'à ce que la mise en oeuvre
commence jusqu'à l'annexion les autres
termes soit à braquer y avoir d'autres
événements les relations avec israël les
états unis pourraient nécessiter
quelques temps après l'application du
plan d'accès la situation actuelle de je
pense que l'une des questions que
décideront les pays arabes demain que
diront-ils après l'annoncé officielle du
plan il pourrait avec l'arrêt au monde
bien ce n'est pas un bon plan
il ne suit pas les frontières de 67 et
pourront s'arrêter là il pourrait aller
encore plus loin il pourrait renvoyer
leurs ambassadeurs israéliens par
exemple ce serait extrêmement dangereux
nous ne parlons que il y est mise en
oeuvre cela prendra du temps
alors l'organisation terroriste un des
terroristes de dèche ont déjà fustigé ce
plan de donald trump sur la paix au
proche orient
le groupe i qui dit vouloir lancer une
nouvelle phase on cible en israël
comment cette information est perçu dans
l'état hébreu avec sérieux et craintes
sont devenues un événement extrêmement
haut niveau au coeur europe a donc il
est rare que l'état islamique qui a
menace directement israël
les forces de sécurité sans aucun doute
réagi vis-à-vis de cette déclaration
mais je ne pense pas que cela change
quoi que ce soit sur le terrain en ce
moment des menaces au niveau de la
frontière syrienne menace sans cesse
donc le niveau de vigilance sécuritaire
est toujours très élevé cela n'a rien de
nouveau
cette menace par contre est nouvelle
c'est une menace très spécifique très
clair sur les actions à venir
la possibilité d'une riposte en israël
est très
mais pourrait également y avoir des
diplômes attaques contre des missions
cessera lienne juive dans le monde
entier cela est déjà arrivé cela peut se
reproduire je pense que le risque à
l'étranger bien plus élevé très élevé
depuis la frappe aérienne du mois
dernier
donc je ne pense pas que cela va changer
beaucoup la situation
merci beaucoup à michel stand avoir été
avec nous en direct ce soir pour notre
rubrique vu de l'extérieur merci à vous
londres entre vendredi soir à 23h dans
la période de transition post break site
jusqu'à la fin de l'année et le royaume
uni et l'union européenne doivent
négocier de nouvelles relations
commerciales
en attendant le négociateur en chef de
l'ue eux mettant en garde aujourd'hui
contre une rupture brutale et celle
wargnier accueilli tout à l'heure à
dublin par le premier ministre irlandais
léo varalda qui juge le royaume uni en
position de faiblesse ont vu des futures
négociations
nous devions tout d'abord organiser ce
break si ce retrait bien organisé et
c'est fait je pense que c'est fait le
premier round est terminé maintenant et
nous devons tout reconstruire
je pense que si vous considérez cela
comme un concours l'union européenne est
en position de force
nous sommes 27 pays nous avons une
population de 450 millions de personnes
et le marché unique est la plus grande
économie du monde
mais je ne pense pas qu'il faille y voir
cela comme un concours nous avons la
possibilité de travailler ensemble
le royaume uni au cours des prochains
mois et d'établir une relation future et
un accord commercial qui soit
mutuellement bénéfique et c'est dans cet
esprit que nous allons entamer ces
discussions et de son entrée au sein de
la cee en 73 à aujourd'hui
londres a souvent entretenu des
relations houleuses avec bruxelles
retour en images
[Musique]
dijoux
et pour en parler nous sommes avec david
xavier weiss auteur du break site et
après aux éditions barton jones merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur rt france
ça y est on y est c'est fait des années
qu'on en parle près des artères normand
cette fois ci c'est la bonne est-ce
qu'on est au bout de nos peines on est
au bout de nos peines en tout cas on est
au bout d'un processus qui a commencé il
ya à peu près trois ans il ya un an
quasiment jour pour jour sur ce plateau
je vous disais compris on aura un brick
site dur et effectivement on y est on
est finalement un truc si dur et ça a
été une confirmation politique puisque
boris johnson à une large majorité pour
le faire
donc il faut en prendre acte maintenant
sur le bilan pour le pour le pour la
grande bretagne je pense qu'il n'est pas
si optimiste que ça si on regarde les
choses en face
on va avoir une grande bretagne qui va
être éclaté avec une demande d'audition
de la part de l'ecosse de l'irlande
que va devenir l'irlande on a donc un
problème institutionnel on aura aussi un
problème économique parce que le coût du
brds exciter la préparation du président
de ces trois années de divorce donc à
l'amiable mais un peu brutal ça a coûté
l'équivalent de quarante sept annuités
de financement au budget européen
donc la grande bretagne a perdu en trois
ans 47 fois le budget qu'elle limete
pour la pour la construction reprenne
maintenant c'est un choix il ya il ya eu
un choix clair des britanniques il on a
voulu ce divorce
il va falloir maintenant l'organiser et
l'organiser ça va aussi prendre beaucoup
de temps parce que divorcé là
aujourd'hui on officialise notre
séparation narration et mais il va
falloir maintenant organiser les
transferts d'énergie
les trans et les accords commerciaux jeu
qui va y avoir maintenant des accords
bilatéraux entre la grande bretagne les
états unis mais la grande-bretagne
russie et l'europe où certains pays
européens
donc on voit bien que toute cette
reconstruction c'est beaucoup de temps
perdu pour au final pas grand chose
c'est un pari politique gagner mais
c'est ap un pari économique qui a abouti
alors le négociateur en chef est
effectivement michel barnier
va mettre en place des négociations un
projet de mandat aux négociations aux
états membres à partir de lundi prochain
ce qu'on a le temps de régler autant de
problèmes compliqués en si peu de temps
alors non c'est bien pour ça qu'on a
déjà une période transitoire de minimum
6 mois entre même la transition est
position paraît l'art est trop courte
bien évidemment et ça va se refaire sur
minimum quatre à cinq ans pour
reconstruire tous les accords bilatéraux
alors bien sûr les plus urgents les plus
importants comme ceux de l'énergie de
l'électricité puisque la grande bretagne
est dépendante ans notamment en matière
d'électricité par rapport à l union au
reste de l'union européenne
il va y avoir des accords très rapide
parce qu'il faut que assurer un minimum
même si on a divorcé il faut pas laisser
son ex épouse dans la détresse donc il
va y avoir des accords ou l'ex mari l'ex
mari voilà il va y avoir des accords
très rapide
et puis il va y avoir une reconstruction
très lente finalement est-ce que ça en
valait le coup parce que le quand même
la grande bretagne sait-on si on remonte
depuis 40 48 ans 47 ans la grande
bretagne avait une europe à la carte pas
dans schengen
elle avait pas l'euro elle avait quand
même eu un statut un petit peu à part
grâce notamment à margaret thatcher qui
avait réussi a finalement joué de sa de
sa personnalité vis-à-vis des autres
pays européens
il avait une europe à la carte très
avantageuse pour eux je vous entende on
se demande ce qui a poussé ces
britannique a voté pour le break 6 et
bien une volonté clarté politique il ya
eu je pense y a trois ans une
instrumentalisation de du sujet briques
cite notamment par rapport à
l'immigration qui était un vrai problème
j'ai toute l'europe notamment mais pas à
pâques pas que la grande bretagne mais
nous aussi et l'allemagne ça a été
instrumentalisée pour gagner des
élections
et c était instrumentalisée à dessein à
des à des fins partisanes politique est
aujourd'hui boris johnson lors du mois
il ya quelques quelques mois boris
johnson a remporté cette élection très
clair parce qu'il fallait bien en sortir
3en à terme ont annoncé comme vous
l'avez dit c'est s était devenue
intenable pour tout le monde notamment
pour les entreprises qui avaient besoin
de savoir sur quel pied danser
sur quels accords commerciaux genou et
est ce que la place financière
la cave est une épice ans plus tôt à
londres est ce que la city va légèrement
se déporter on l'espère un petit peu à
paris beaucoup à francfort du moins il
va y avoir
recomposition en matière de finances
voilà il y à il ya toutes ces choses qui
sont devant nous et qui nous réserve
encore beaucoup de surprises là et on
n'est pas terminée en ce moment on voit
qu'il ya une fébrilité
michel barnier qui met en garde contre
le risque d'une rupture brutale des
échanges entre le royaume uni et l'union
européenne dans le même temps boris
johnson qui menace de taxer les
européens les allemands sur leurs
voitures nous sur le fromage on est dans
un coup de poker menteur
on est sur un coup de poker menteur où
c'est en plus brute johnson il a il est
conseillé il a comme modèle le président
américain donald trump qui à la russe
voilà on sent on semble parfaitement le
l'inspiration je ne sait pas en revanche
si ça marche avec l'europe l'europe qui
a des traditions anciennes ce vieux
continent qui a des traditions
diplomatiques quand même beaucoup plus
feutrée alors peut-être que ça peut
marcher mais l'union européenne n'attend
pas que après le après la grande
bretagne
ça peut marcher avec la chine parce que
vous avez entre les états unis la chine
des accords commerciaux et des accords
financiers tellement lourd là dès la
dette de la chine que la dette de la des
états unis qui est tenu par la chine etc
le rapport de force entre la
grande-bretagne et l'europe du moins le
reste de l'union européenne
il n'est pas forcément en faveur de la
grande bretagne et mais je pense que de
toute façon pour les jeunes soit va
sûrement jouer cette carte du coup de
poker en permanence qu'est ce qui se
joue aujourd'hui finalement c'est très
important ce qui va se passer ces
prochaines semaines ce kit pour les uns
et des autres et ce qui est et ce qui
est problématique pour un inquiétant
c'est notamment pour la vie au quotidien
de dd franco-britannique de ceux qui ont
des échanges réguliers avec avec l'ombre
de ceux qui travaillent à londres qui
revit qui reviennent le week-end à paris
peureux il va y avoir d une vraie
période d'adaptation
ne serait-ce que sur un plan
administratif la wii et ça peut poser
non pas des problèmes mais des
tracasseries effectivement il va y avoir
un sujet plus lourd sur l'énergie et
puis ensuite à moyen terme un
rééquilibrage bad et des forces
notamment sur le monde de la finance
effectivement on sent bien aujourd'hui
que la city est en train n'ont pas de
vaciller parce que l'équilibré
l'épicentre de la finance des quand même
elle reste
mais on voit bien qu'il ya des grandes
banques comme la société générale etc
qui rapatrient leurs effectifs à paris
d'une part et dans le reste de l'union
européenne
donc la grande bretagne elle a gagné sur
un plan politique
oui une vraie une vraie partie sur un
plan économique et diplomatique
elle commence à s'isoler et sur un plan
institutionnel vraiment je pense qu'ils
devraient faire attention parce que
aujourd'hui vous avez l'ecosse et
l'irlande qui sont légitimes pour
demander plus d'autonomie
est-ce que c'est pas finalement la fin
du royaume uni où c'est le début du
royaume désunis merci beaucoup on
terminera sur cette formule david xavier
weiss d'avoir été avec nous en direct
sur rt france la contestation populaire
ne faiblit pas en irak un manifestant a
été tué et quatre autres blessés à
naciria dans le sud du pays
heures également à bagdad entre forces
de sécurité et militants anti
gouvernementaux et pierre l'ambassade
des etats-unis a été pris ce produit par
trois roquettes dont une s'est écrasé
sur sa cafétéria bilan un blessé selon
un haut responsable irakien attaques non
revendiquées mais washington a cloué
movies proche de téhéran iraniens et
américains plus que jamais à tous tout
irait
[Musique]
[Rires]
oui
[Musique]
dans quelques instants rester avec nous
notre débat sur les propos d'emmanuel
mettront dans l'avion qui le ramenait
d'israël évoquant dans ma même
conversation guerre d'algérie et chaud à
la france doit-elle revisiter la mémoire
de la guerre d'algérie pour mettre un
terme à je cite au jour ceci conflit
mémorielle nous en débattrons avec nos
invités
[Musique]
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous s'il arrive
quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
coupe
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du bon vieux cash
nous vous parlerons de tout sans langue
de bois
comme on le sait donnant pas seulement
le cinéma
ils sont le cinéma
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
charles pathé a le génie des affaires
léon gaumont est un ingénieur surdoué
ces deux hommes que tout opposait se
sont forgé une destinée commune dans une
perpétuelle surenchère ils ont bâti
chacun leur empire et dominer le monde
[Musique]
et
les news ne s'arrête jamais mais c'est
votre soutien que nous apprécions le
plus
[Musique]
on
le week et geoffroy deux frères animé
par leur passion pour l'eau ont décidé
d'emprunter les routes de la soie sur
les traces des premiers échanges entre
les civilisations
en quatre mois de la chine à paris et
parcours sur leur side car plus de 15000
kilomètres à travers l'asie centrale et
l'asie mineure pour revivre l'évolution
du commerce mondial et son impact sur la
ressource en eau
[Musique]
souvent quand la violence déborde
nous répondons au plus vite et c'est
pour cette raison que les salvadoriens
nous font confiance
longtemps
[Musique]
j'ai sauvé des vies d'enfants les
personnes âgées des jeunes
peu importe qu'ils soient des criminels
mon travail consiste à sauver des vies
les gangs sont la réalité dans laquelle
les jeunes générations en dise
je ne sais pas ce que je serais devenu
si j'étais resté là où je vivais à
l'époque
certains disent que nous ne sommes pas
une chaîne française
d'autres affirment même que nous ne
sommes pas journalistes mais vous
savez-vous vraiment qui nous sommes
les valeurs que nous défendons la
liberté
la liberté d'expression et d'opinion
nous défendons l'égalité l'égalité des
chances pour tous
[Musique]
nous sommes une équipe
nous sommes cette diversité qui fait la
france
et nous en sommes fiers
[Musique]
et si vous veniez voir par vous même
21h30 soyez les bienvenus en direct sur
rt france merci nous rejoindra shoah et
guerre d'algérie les mode emmanuel
macron créé la polémique jeudi dernier
depuis l'elysée tentent d'éteindre les
braises et nuancent les propos du
président retour sur la sphère en images
[Musique]
je suis très lucide sur les défis que
j'ai devant moi d'un point de vue
mémorielle et qui sont politiques
la guerre d'algérie est sans doute le
plus dramatique je sais depuis ma
compagne il est là et je pense qu'il a à
peu près le même statut que la shoah
pour chirac en 1995
[Musique]
répétant l'expression de crimes contre
l'humanité emmanuel macron rapproche
maintenant la guerre d'algérie de la
shoah indécence absolue
ses propos sont à la fois une folie pour
l'histoire et la mémoire et bombe à
retardement pour notre avenir
comparé la shoah à la guerre d'algérie
est obscène
emmanuel macron est en pleine dérive
la shoah et le crime absolu qui ne peut
être comparée à aucun autre
le président a réaffirmé l'unicité de la
shoah elle est indiscutable
[Musique]
alors mal interprété ou mal formulé peut
être regretter les propos d' emmanuel
macron en tout cas ont suscité des
réactions et relance le débat sur
l'algérie la france doit-elle revisiter
la mémoire de cette guerre pour mettre
un terme aux jeux sip conflit mémorielle
c'est l'objet de notre face à face ce
soir et pour en débattre en somme avec
m'hamed kaki président de l'association
mémorielle les oranje bonsoir mais merci
d'être avec nous à ses côtés franck
crudo contributeur au site causeur qui
s'est exprimé dans une tribune ce matin
sur ce sujet merci messieurs d'être
venus débattre sur cette question cette
polémique même si on l'a vu à l'elysée a
tenté un rétro pédalage mais pour vous
ces propos fortuit voulu m'hamed kaki
comment on les avait ressenti je les
restes sont surtout dans un contexte
politique particulier qui sont dans un
mois et demi des élections municipales
et le président de la république est
coutumier du fait que de draguer un
certain nombre d' électorat dont
l'électorat des français héritiers de
l'immigration coloniale et donc dans ce
contexte là je ne suis pas étonné de
cette erreur ou cette confusion des
histoires qui est bien évidemment je le
dis d'emblée ça n'a rien à voir
histoire des crimes coloniaux et
l'histoire de la shoah sont des
histoires différentes dans des contextes
historiques complètement différent
néanmoins
l'histoire coloniale nous allons aussi
en parler rennes se pose est est une
histoire aussi très importante et qui ne
s'arrête pas seulement à ce qu'on
appelle la guerre d'algérie c'est à dire
le 1er novembre 1954 au a jusqu'en 1962
c'est bien plus large que ça l'histoire
coloniale en algérie a démarré en 1830
franck un credo vous votre réaction à
ces propos d' emmanuel macron avec y
compris le rétropédalage un qui va avec
oui alors bon je vous avoue je sais plus
trop quoi penser du président c'est ce
que je disais vous disais à l'instant
l'antenne ce que j'ai quand même le
sentiment qu'ils s'adaptent un peu à son
auditoire et qu'il est capable de dire
tout et son contraire en fonction de
l'endroit où ils se trouvent face à des
gens de gauche la tendance à gauchisé
son discours des gens de droite à
droitiser en algérie nous parle de
crimes contre l'humanité là maintenant
effectivement pour la shoah il tient un
discours totalement différent bon bah
c'est ce qu'on appelle le en même temps
mac revenir mais ça peut être aussi ses
limites parfois alors le chef de l'état
en tous cas s'est dit convaincu que la
france devait je cite revisiter la
mémoire de la guerre d'algérie pour
mettre un terme au conflit mémorielle
qui rend la chose très dur en france qui
parlait du statut de jacques chirac en
1995 lors de la reconnaissance de la fld
du vel d'hiv est ce que ça vous choque
ça de m le même statut heures sans faire
le parallèle entre ces deux ces deux
événements dramatiques mais est ce que
est ce que on est là est ce qui est une
forme de sincérité selon vous quand même
m'hamed kaki écouter les analogies sont
pas toujours fortuite
c'est toujours compliqué quand on
commence à faire des analogies des
rapprochements
il faut je crois à laisser le travail
aux historiens qui le font très bien et
il faut s'en inspirer d'abord il faut un
travail rigoureux et je pense que c'est
effectivement une erreur mais en même
temps et vous connaissez ma position
rond emmanuel macron gelé combattu
notamment pour le mouvement social et
pour les retraites
eh bien je crois que là il a sur
notamment il a avancé sur un certain
nombre de choses notamment la
reconnaissance pour maurice audin la
veuve de maurice audin vous savez
qu'elle amenait un axe un travail et
autour d'elle une association d'ailleurs
qui s'appelle maurice audin exulter
naquirent les téléspectateurs qui
maurice audace et un mathématicien qui
était en algérie et qui avait pris fait
et cause pour les algériens pour contre
la torture contre les exactions contre
toutes ces humiliations et le poison
général de la colonisation et il a été
kidnappé on va dire par l'armée
française à l'époque et il a disparu
il a disparu alors on sait que il a été
torturé à mort par un certain nombre de
gens effectivement des militaires est
aujourd'hui le fait que le président de
la république a reconnu qu'il y avait
bel et bien que maurice audin a été
assassiné que c'est un véritable crime
et qu'il n'est pas mort comme ça disparu
eh bien ces taxes est une avancée
importante non seulement pour le savoir
la connaissance mais aussi pour tous les
gens qui sont morts pour rien et ça je
pense que bien que ce soit l'adversaire
nous lui devons cette reconnaissance là
et c'est une avancée à la fois pour la
science mais aussi pour l'apaisement
ce qu'on a parce que qu'est ce qu'on
recherche ils sont recherche ici c'est
aussi créer les conditions du
rapprochement entre les peuples entre le
peuple français et les deux rives de la
méditerranée comme on dit le peuple
algérien qui sont tout à fait prêts
d'ailleurs les peuples non
non pas j'allais dire de haine entre les
uns et des autres et donc c'est ça qui
est important et je crois qu'il faut lui
reconnaître cette cette initiative qui
était importante cependant on est loin
du compte
le compte n'est pas là notamment sur la
question de la reconnaissance des crimes
coloniaux en algérie alors évidemment
qui comme je le disais tout à l'heure
ils ont commencé avec le général du jour
fameuse phrase tuez les tous qui n'en
reste pas un seul avec le 8 mai 1945 où
il ya eu 45 mille morts entre le 8 mai
1945 et le 30 septembre 1945
c'est un désastre sans compter les
spoliations le fait d'affamer les
peuples le peuple
le fait de détruire les structures du
savoir 1 parce que ça a eu des effets
sur la colonisation c'est une chose d'un
véritable poison
hier comme aujourd'hui parce que la
colonisation n'est pas terminée dans le
monde et en même temps elle a eu des
effets importants pour les générations
qui sont arrivés parce que vous avez ça
alors que l'algérie est un pays de
savants et bien on en a fait à l'époque
on a tout détruit le comment dire
l'armée française a détruit beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup de choses et
effectivement je crois que aujourd'hui
tout ça c'est du passé bien sûr mais il
faut reconnaître et la reconnaissance
chère madame n'est pas la repentance on
va en parler à tout à l'heure je vous
propose d'écouter tout d'abord un
historien jean sevilla et historien
essayiste pour qui cette comparaison
emmanuel macron entre la shoah et de la
guerre d'algérie s'apparente à de la
folie sur le plan historique affirmé que
la guerre d'algérie pourrait avoir à peu
près le même statut que celui qui avait
la shoah pour chirac en 95 semble
annoncer une reconnaissance de
culpabilité de la france dans la guerre
d'algérie ce à quoi se sont opposés tous
les présidents qui ont précédé emmanuel
macron quoi qu'on en pense
c'est de la folie sur tous les plans
historique politique et diplomatique
le simple énoncé de cette idée est
obscène d'abord par rapport à la shoah
qui perd alors sa singularité et son
ampleur sur le plan numérique la shoah
c'est près de six millions de morts
la guerre d'algérie c'est entre 250 et
300 mille morts dans les deux camps
franck renaud est ce qu'on peut dire
quand même ça eu le mérite
de lancer le débat où vous trouver
effectivement que c'est complètement
incongrues ce genre de comparaison même
encore une fois ci à uvrer tropez
dommage depuis
l'analogie entre la guerre d'algérie et
la shoah et même le terme de crimes
contre l'humanité un des propos qu
apparemment le président a assumé en
tout cas n'a pas regretté me semble
effectivement pour le moins assez
choquant vous savez moi je me méfie
toujours des curseurs qu'on pousse trop
loin
quel que soit ce sujet d'ailleurs d'un
côté comme de l'autre si on faisait
partie d'un pays qui célébrait son
histoire avec une certaine arrogance
arrogance pardon sans aucun recul sans
aucun esprit critique y compris envers
ces heures sombres
j'aurais tendance à dire qu'il faudrait
peut-être effectivement faire un devoir
de mémoire
essayez de s'interroger sur ces heures
sombres
mais a contrario si on fait partie d'un
pays et j'ai un peu peur que ça soit le
cas aujourd'hui qui pousse les curseurs
très loin en termes de repentance de
discours de surenchère de concurrence
victimaire avec tous les effets pervers
que cela peut provoquer ça ne suis pas
complètement d'accord avec ce que vous
venez de dire vous êtes là pour débattre
je pense qu'aujourd'hui on pousse
tellement loin le curseur dans la
victimisation notamment la repentance
l'autoflagellation que ça pour effet
pervers notamment de 2 comment dire de
de créer encore plus de ressentiment
notamment vers des populations
certaines communautés à notre égard là
où me semble-t-il il faudrait peut-être
rééquilibrer plutôt le curseur et dire
bon ben on va peut-être y allez un petit
peu plus mollo sur la repentance ou le
la victimisation et essayer de faire et
neigé j'ai terminé rassure guère oui
mais essayez de faire peut-être aimé un
peu plus long mais ça notre pays à
tomber et qui je vous répondrais
finissait voilà non mais écoutez
voilà j'ai dit l'essentiel je pense
qu'il faudrait peut-être essayer de
faire une minable davantage notre pays
aux gens issus de l'immigration aux
jeunes issus de l'immigration plutôt
qu'à chaque fois de leur donner des
raisons de le détester
surtout que ces analogies ou ce discours
me semble extrêmement discutable sur le
plan intellectuel et terriblement contre
productive voire dangereux alors je suis
absolument pas d'accord avec ça mais
c'est votre position moi je crois
d'abord en termes des douanes chomsky
disaient les mots font le monde et vous
savez moi je n'aime pas le mot issu 2 je
pense que nous sommes les français
héritier c'est un héritage est un
héritage de combat un héritage important
et la deuxième chose qui est très
importante que nos téléspectateurs
doivent savoir c'est que cette histoire
de l'histoire coloniale n'est pas le
fait de l'histoire des algériens ou des
malgaches ou ou dans n'importe quel pays
qui a été colonisé c'est l'histoire de
france et donc les français sont amputés
d'une grande partie de leur histoire et
qui font leur restituer d'un point de
vue scientifique c'est déjà ça le
problème
et moi quand je rencontre des des amis
avec qui j'ai grandi
ce qu'on est tous des français et bien
qu'ils connaissent pas cette pente de
l'histoire je trouve ça malheureux est
dommageable simplement pour la question
de l'histoire
ses premiers points et j'ai dit tout à
l'heure de ce qu'ils auraient fait que
j'étais tout à leur tende et monsieur
j'ai dit tout à l'heure que la
reconnaissance n'est pas la repentance
la reconnaissance a justement pour but
la question de l'altérité latérite et
c'est quoi
faire en sorte que l'autre existe et si
vous dites est bien que la
reconnaissance et la repentance il ya
nécessairement là n'implique pas
nécessairement l'aube selon vous m'hamed
kaki quand on reconnaît d'une certaine
manière on se repentit non pas du tout
non mais c'est pas du tout justement je
récuse totalement cette dialectique là
que je connais bien qui fait partie de
tout un pan politique de la société
française c'est ctu derrière ça il ya
toute une stratégie un alors vous fait
pas le procès monsieur avoue mais je
sais que d'ailleurs c'est très curieux
on n'a pas relevé depuis tout à l'heure
quand même qu'un faux quelles sont les
personnes qui se sont élevés contre de
manière violente contre monsieur macron
eh bien c'est la droite et l'extrême
droite
or en matière de lutte contre
l'antisémitisme
on peut faire mieux rappelez vous
monsieur le pen avec la sphère du détail
1 par rapport à la choix c'est quand
même un scandale qu'un homme politique
oui mais ça continue
vous savez sont des artères défilent et
ça continue au jour d'aujourd'hui c'est
toujours à l'ordre par exemple associer
sa fille marine le pen puisqu'on parle
d'elle puisque c'est la présidente
aujourd'hui du rassemblement national
héritière du fn vous vous la mettez
entre guillemets dans le même sac que
son père il ya eu effectivement ces mots
- c'est toujours la même mouvance de
l'extrême droite violente et qui
justement journée n'aurait d'ailleurs
pas vraiment de l'état et qui met la
droite c'est pareil
vous saviez 2 droite les républicains et
non non non justement il ya deux droites
pour moi il ya celle du général de
gaulle qui a combattu le nazisme le
fascisme et cela chapeau bas et puis
vous avez les vichystes vous avez le
général le maréchal pétain et vous avez
tous ceux qui ont enlevé la nationalité
française aux juifs faut se rappeler de
ça 1 ceux qui ont balancé les juifs au
nazis et bien tous ces nostalgiques là
il reste encore il existe encore et des
qu'effectivement il ya une ouverture de
dialogue
et encore une fois macron c'est pas mon
copain mais il arrive nous enterrons est
ce que pour vous l'antisémitisme
aujourd'hui en france et en premier lieu
de l'extrême droite il aux 8 eh bien il
vient de partout mais l'extrême droite
on sait très bien c'est justement vif en
france depuis 1945 a tenté sans délai
ces importants ce qui fait c'est
l'extrême droite et d'idéologie c'est
l'idéologie véhiculée par l'extrême
droite notamment aux violents d'extrême
droite qui tuer les juifs en france
dames on a très envie de bien évidemment
c'était la gênait pas seulement ça
évidemment il y en a il ya aussi ça
vient aussi d'autres d'autre part mais
principalement la question de
systématiquement d'une part et ceux à
qui j'ai donné vraiment la question de
l'idéologie nanotech soir des musulmans
radicaux dans ces qui ont tué les juifs
des points 75 en face à un seul nom
l'offre m3 d'eau et serait moche ça
c'est tellement fou avant c'est
totalement faux oui absolument faux il
ya des gens qui se disent à biais de
deux des vêtements de l'islam mais qui
n'ont rien à voir avec l'islam et enfin
j'aime encore denses en revanche ils
sont donc immenses enjeux ne sont pas
d'explosion arabi d'extrême non c'est
pas mes amis allaient bien et bien eux
moi je vous rassure intitulé un véhicule
et a coûté pourquoi
pourquoi vous dites que mes amis dit
c'est moi j'ai un rejet de toute forme
parce qu'il me semble que le journal
dans lequel vous êtes quand même a
toujours la même obsession c'est à dire
l'islamophobie
c'est à dire la haine non musulmans
sujet des effectifs comprends que vous
refusiez cette idée d'amalgamé on vous
comprend bien mais vous réfutez
aujourd'hui qui est un antisémitisme
voilà ce nouvel antisémitisme comme on
dit qui vient effectivement de de
l'islam aujourd'hui en france est ce que
vous le contesté par l'islam pas de
l'islam
des gens qui se revendique soul et la
cagoule de l'islam et donc ça il faut
faire attention à ce que michael a
justement ce que vous venez de dire mais
dans les lycées le savez il ya des gens
qui se disent ne sont pas musulmans ils
se prétendent non ils sont pas musulmans
parce que parce qu'un vrai musulman ne
tue pas un vrai musulman ne le
n'assassine pas un vrai musulman c'est
quelqu'un qui a de l'amour et de et qui
veut la paix et donc la vérité monsieur
l'accord donc donc pas de confusion mais
ce sont effectivement mais j'essaye de
suivre votre raisonnement donc du coup
marc dutroux n'est pas belge adolf
eichmann n'est pas allemands parce que
l'allemagne c'est mieux c'est
mais j'ai l'impression vous avez une
vision idéalisée des choses dans un
monde idéal par me dire que l'islam n'a
rien à voir avec l'islamisme que ce ne
sont pas des musulmans c'est un débat
vieux comme le monde mais là c'est quand
même à ce titre là le cas du suédois qui
a qui a assassiné des gens est ce qu est
ce qu il représente l'ensemble des
suédois un norvégien norvégien pardon le
norvégien 1 et dans chaque pays il y a
des gens qui sont des fous il en riant
la miss laissera pas sa vision qui
n'avait mis la main sur quelqu'un c'est
pas parce qu'ils se revendique au nom
est d'ailleurs monsieur monsieur
d'ailleurs le débat ici c'est pas
l'islam d'accord si vous le voulez bien
on va revenir peut-être quand même sur
la question
bien sûr cette l'idée en tout cas aux
loyalistes prud'hommes été
mettez en avant ce côté weir pendant ce
pour finalement divisé les uns et les
autres
est ce que il n'ya pas de ça aussi
m'hamed kaki
est-ce qu'il faut reconnaître se
repentir peut-être est-ce qu'il ya pas
une fille ça n'entraîne pas forcément
une division mettre les uns contre les
autres faire forcément de caen à votre
avis vous qui justement être vrai pour
la paix et stéphanie c'est juste voilà
c'est l'objet de mon travail c'est moi
je avec mes amis en oeuvre pour la
reconnaissance pour la reconnaissance du
savoir pour le fait qu'on serait ce
parce qu'on est tous français et que on
vit sept ans comme un ensemble à travers
notre république et à l'intérieur de
laquelle tous les projets que je mène
par exemple les conférences-débats
restée bloc mais aussi le théâtre on a
c'est pour faire en sorte que les jeunes
français puissent acquérir cette
connaissance de l'histoire
mais comment leur cache une grande
partie de cette histoire là notamment
les médias parce que moi je vais vous
raconter quelque chose tout à l'heure
qui m'a porté sur ce bateau j'ai eu un
prof d'histoire-géo spécialiste de la
choix puisque on parle évidemment de cet
événement à l'occasion du 75e
anniversaire de la libération des cons
qui me disait en terminale on laisse aux
professeurs le fait de choisir entre
l'enseignement de la mémoire de la
guerre d'algérie et l'enseignement de la
mémoire de la shoah
c'est un prof d'histoire-géographie un
qui m'a dit oui sur ce plateau
qu'est ce que ça vous évoque sa alors
moi ce qui m'évoque surtout c'est que
l'éducation nationale mais de moins en
moins de moyens
vous le savez assez singulier entre les
genres oui c'est aberrant c'est aberrant
qu'on puisse avoir le choix soit la
guerre d'algérie soit la joie il faut
connaître les deux il faut connaître les
2es et par ailleurs c'est c'est aussi la
question du budget parce que vous savez
qu'ils ont resserré les boulons et
qu'aujourd'hui la l'enseignement de
l'histoire et peau de chagrin et peau de
chagrin au lycée au collège etc et donc
au détriment de
dudar serrage de boulons d'une manière
générale et je crois que ça c'est un
vrai problème et ça ne devrait pas
exister ce que vous dites c'est un gars
de notre débat je trouve ça assez
troublant mois se joue ici vous aller
enseigner la shoah viendra jerry c'est
aberrant c'est aberrant il faut
l'histoire c'est la connaissance est ce
qui nous permettent de nous connaître
et puis d'être j'allais dire de se
comprendre et même si on n'est pas
d'accord quelquefois mais en tout cas de
nous comprendre et et l'histoire et les
sciences sociales en général ça permet
ça permet cela et je crois que c'est
dommageable
donc l'histoire coloniale qui est très
mal enseignée moi ce que je voulais
c'est souligner quand même une chose
très importante c'est le nombre de morts
entre 1830 et 1962 parce que moi je ne
me concentre pas uniquement sur
l'histoire de la guerre d'algérie qui a
duré entre 54 et 62
vous savez la violence avec laquelle
s'est mise en place la politique de
peuplement en algérie est inouïe c'est à
dire la spoliation le fait d'affamer les
gens le fait de les exterminer
d'une manière générale d'une manière ou
d'une autre c'est à dire quand vous
affamer les frais de vous répondre
est ce qu'il ya un peu plus de temps de
parole s'il veut dire de votre mais le
terme d'extermination déjà est
extrêmement connoté si je peux me
permettre un peu effrayant mais je vois
beaucoup de choses vous
oui parce qu'on parle d'histoire
coloniale oui ça c'est surtout
l'analogie avec la shoah pédagogie mois
oui enfin c'est le un peu le sujet et
c'est la nageuse l'analogique a fait le
président de macron est-ce que vous par
exemple justement puisque vous parler de
ce sujet est ce que vous estimez que la
guerre d'algérie est un crime contre
l'humanité de la part de la france alors
vous reprendriez les propos du président
moi je parle de crime colonial est un
crime contre l'humanité coloniale
c'est à dire que la question du crime
colonial s'est il y a des choses qui
ressemblent d'en camp
ça dépend des périodes c'est pour ça que
c'est extrêmement compliqué on dialogue
avec les historiens etc
il faut instruments de ce point de vue
là et bien les crimes coloniaux ça
consistait notamment à une période
donnée vous avez le général du jour
lorsque lui avec les enfumades ce que
vous connaissez les enfumades quand on a
enfermé les gens dans les grottes et
faire des feux à l'entrée des de ces
grottes et que les gens mouraient comme
ça ça a été terrible donc il y a eu des
moments où il ya eu des processus
d'extermination mais il ya eu d'autres
moments beaucoup plus apaisé on va dire
qu'il n'ya pas de crime contre lui je ne
parlerai pas de crimes coloniaux contre
l'humanité systématique dac
en revanche il y a eu des moments dont
l'histoire coloniale en algérie où il a
eu des processus d'extermination
faudrait enfin côté benjamin stora
pardon va vous allez répondre en credo
parce qu'il nous reste peu de temps
l'historien qui affirme y l'absence de
procès sur ce conflit algérien est un
véritable obstacle à la réconciliation
si on veut comparer avec la question de
la shoah
outre le travail historique les procès
celui de klaus barbie ou de maurice
papon ont été de formidable accélérateur
des moments de cristallisation de
dévoilement historique des réalités
l'absence de procès sur le conflit
algérien est un véritable obstacle
réconcilie les mémoires n'est d'ailleurs
pas qu'un enjeu mémoriel
c'est une nécessité historique l'algérie
est un grand pays
une clé pour de nombreux enjeux comme la
question migratoire ou le terrorisme
on ne peut pas se permettre d'avoir des
relations ambiguës avec ce pays
fran credo vous critiquiez ce côté auto
flagellation est ce qu'un procès se
serait pas effectivement là la première
solution pour appeler sur la guerre
d'algérie
oui notamment sur la guerre d'algérie on
va terminer
là dessus oui enfin moi l'absence de
procès je regrette c'est surtout celui
c'est un autre sujet enfin ça le rejoint
un peu sur madame admis sur son meurtre
ça j'aurais bien aimé qu'il y ait un
procès notamment dans l'analogie oui non
parce que il ya quand même un petit
rapport avec notre ici on fait ça
oui mais on on parle justement des
bienfaits d'un procès je pense qu'à ce
titre est d'ailleurs le président d'un
cran elle a évoqué lui même en israël
mais moi si vous voulez j'essaye de
comprendre votre raisonnement en fait
est ce que j'ai envie de vous poser
cette question ne se tait qui est ce que
pour vous la france est la seule
responsable des atrocités durant la
guerre d'algérie ou est-ce que les torts
sont partagés selon vous écouter la
france a colonisé l'algérie donc la
première responsabilité c'est d'abord
que l'avenant vassaliser d'abord oui et
elle a détruit des écoles à la détruit
des universités elle a fracassé un pays
pendant 132 ans
parce que si on veut revenir à la hausse
y construire les écoles d'escaladé pour
qui pour qui les européens mais moi je
vais vous le dire ella ella elle a créé
un cercle géographiques et toutes les
terres arables non pas arabe arables qui
qui était cultivables elle a laissé les
indigènes crevé deux dans l'année donc
donc si vous voulez c'est pour ça que
c'est extrêmement compliqué c'est d'une
violence inouïe et d'ailleurs je dois
dire que nos anciens sont bien gentils
ils nous ont transmis que de l'amour
c'est ça qui est formidable je veux dire
que avec l'argument de m
la violence qui a eu avec l'avenant et
l'avait ans qu'ils ont subi les anciens
en transmis toujours l'idée qu'il
fallait dialoguer et continuer
excusez-moi internet ici
suit votre raisonnement la france est
avant tout coupable d'avoir colonisé
cette terre qui n'est pareil donc du
coup vous seriez prêt également à
demander pardon pour la colonisation de
l'espagne par exemple par les musulmans
pendant huit siècles par la colonisation
par les ottomans d'une partie de la
roche sur yon monsieur je suis français
oui je ne suis pas parce que là vous
venez de vous demander monsieur qui vous
dit que je suis musulman dans les airs
mais attendez là on est en tant que la
question de ma position est vive et ne
vous ne regarde personne ici d'accord
ici moi je suis dans l'ensemble rien
c'est normal qu'on demande pardon
également pour la colonisation n'est ce
pas ailleurs par ailleurs les documents
par ailleurs l'ue musulmans du point de
vue de l'histoire parce que toute
l'année la chanson condamnable si je
suis votre raisonnement
le subventionnement la colonisation
d'espagne ont justement on débat sur la
langue da luz merci d'avoir accepté de
jouer le jeu de ce débat sur des sujets
parfois effectivement sensible mais
voilà il y avait deux habits
contradictoires c'était l'essentiel
merci à vous deux on se retrouve dans
quelques petites minutes pour 1 point
complet sur l'actualité
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'ai fort potentiel programme moi et je
ferai que ce que tu veux toi tu es un
gros boom ned et viennent entre humains
je vous emmène découvrir les robots les
plus high tech qui vont bientôt sortir
de leur laboratoire pour rentrer dans
nos maisons
[Musique]
l'ère des robots approche nous avons
l'opportunité de pouvoir changer le
monde
ceux-ci excitant ils vont changer notre
manière de nous divertir d'apprendre de
communiqué en fait il y avait changé
notre vie
[Musique]
alors là ce n'est pas tellement
difficile mais les gens s'étonnent
toujours que je conduise une voiture
c'est simple je n'ai pas peur et je
crois en moi maintenant je suis
chauffeur de taxi qu'est ce qui peut
arriver
j'ai été blessé à la guerre j'ai décidé
le symbole de ma bien aimée
r la première lettre de son nom round
je remercie allah que la voir épouser
[Musique]
l'état m'a proposé de travailler dans le
domaine du gaz
je sens que j'ai retrouvé la vie normale
j'ai commencé à parler avec les gens
nous avons des poules des vaches des
moutons des terrains des agrumes dans le
verger
ma vie ne s'est pas interrompue francs
chacun dumont bras
[Musique]
history pour israël contestée par les
palestiniens donald trump dévoilera
demain 18 heures son plan de paix pour
le moyen-orient qui selon lui a une
chance d'aboutir un texte qui divise
alors que benjamin netanyahu et benny
gantz ont reçu respectivement
aujourd'hui à la maison blanche
75 ans après la libération des camps
d'auschwitz birkenau emmanuel macron
appelé à ne rien céder face à
l'insupportable regard de
l'antisémitisme au mémorial de la shoah
à paris
en pologne le premier ministre edouard
philippe à lui souligné la radicale
pardies l'humanité après sa visite du
camp c'était il ya six ans l'usiné
goodyear d'amiens nord fermé
volet judiciaire est lui loin d'être
terminée demain après des années de
bataille ce sont plus de 800 ex goodyear
déterminer qui ont rendez vous devant le
conseil des prud'hommes
merci de nous rejoindre en direct sur rt
france bienvenue à d'autres benyamin
netanyahu doivent s'exprimer demain
depuis la maison blanche au menu le plan
de paix des états unis pour le
moyen-orient
un texte encore non dévoilé mais déjà
jugé historique par l'état hébreu
écoutez les précisions à tel aviv de
notre reporter thomas bonne et les yeux
sont rivés vers washington et
l'annoncent à venir de ce fameux deal du
siècle est tel qu'il est présenté par le
président américain donald trump en
consultant les premières fuites qui
circulent ici dans les médias israéliens
on peut s'attendre à un plan qui serait
calqué sur les mesures souhaitées par
benyamin netanyahou et son parti et ce
n'est pas un hasard si le premier
ministre israélien qui est en
déplacement à washington a eu des mots
très élogieux à l'égard du locataire de
la maison blanche estimant qu'il était
je cite le plus grand ami qu'israël
n'ait jamais eue
alors ce plan a été élaboré en secret
depuis maintenant près de trois ans
notamment par le gendre de donald trump
et selon les premières mesures qui
circulent dans les médias israéliens il
pourrait appliquer la souveraineté
totale d'israël sur de nombreuses
colonies et sur l'ensemble de la ville
de jérusalem ou encore demander la
démilitarisation complète de la bande de
gaza en contrepartie les états unis à
investir et à hauteur de 50 milliards
dans les territoires palestiniens et
dans les pays arabes voisins
c'est un plan qui est d'ores et déjà
rejetée par les palestiniens à l'image
de secrétaire général de l'organisation
de libération de la palestine qui menace
de se retirer des accords d'oslo des
accords qui avaient été conclus dans les
années 90 il faut dire que les
palestiniens n'ont pas vraiment été
conviés aux discussions et qu'il rejette
de toute manière tout dialogue avec
washington depuis que donald trump a
décidé de déplacer l'ambassade des états
unis dans la ville de jérusalem on a les
palestiniens très en colère contre le
président américain plusieurs centaines
de palestiniens ont manifesté ce lundi
pour afficher leur rejet du plan juppé
de donald trump
il imite ont mis le feu à son effigie
depuis son arrivée à la maison blanche
de notre homme qui affirme vouloir
résoudre le conflit israélo palestinien
tout en affichant un soutien
indéfectible à l'état hébreu et un
accord entre les deux pays
qui serait très favorable à israël selon
claude blanchemaison expert en relations
internationales
ici il s'agit d'un accord qui
probablement donne un certain nombre de
satisfactions juridique à israël
probablement l'annexion de la vallée du
jourdain
l'annexion de certaines de certains
territoires où il ya déjà des colonies
peut-être d'autres choses comme le
désarmement de la bande de gaza la
contrepartie de tout ça c'est une sorte
de plan marshall pour la palestine c'est
à dire beaucoup d'argent beaucoup
l'investissement sauf que évidemment les
palestiniens ne seront pas d'accord
puisqu'ils n'ont pas été associés à la
confection de ce plan ils ont d'ailleurs
averti que si ce plan dont on ne connaît
pas encore les détails étaient mises en
oeuvre il sortirait des accords d'oslo
ce qui serait grave parce qu'il ya des
accords de partage des responsabilités
notamment sécuritaire entre israël et
l'autorité palestinienne donc ce serait
évidemment très grave mais la france
appelle les états unis à maintenir leur
soutien militaire dans la lutte contre
les djihadistes dans le sahel
la miss française des armes et florence
parly cet entretien au pentagone à ce
sujet avec le ministre américain de la
défense marque espère mais ce dernier a
assuré que les discussions devaient se
poursuivre entre les deux alliés
rien n'était encore décidé logiciels
américain à nos opérations une
importance cruciale et sa diminution
limiterait gravé en l'efficacité de nos
opérations contre les terroristes
il a été dit la décision n'est pas
encore prise
aucune décision n'a encore été prise et
nous les prendrons en temps voulu j'ai
des consultations avec madame par l'idée
depuis plusieurs mois et nous
continuerons à en avoir avant de prendre
des décisions
la journée internationale dédiée à la
mémoire des victimes de l'holocauste il
ya 75 ans jour pour jour l'armée rouge
libérer le camp de concentration et
d'extermination d'auschwitz le premier
ministre français edouard philippe et en
pologne où il a déposé une gerbe sur le
mur de la mort lieu où ont été fusillés
des milliers de prisonniers et bien
moscou une exposition s'est ouverte
aujourd'hui sur ce thème la
correspondance en russie d'antoine
claireaux à l'occasion de la soixante
quinzième journée internationale dédiée
à la mémoire des victimes de
l'holocauste le musée juif et centre de
tolérance de moscou présente sa toute
nouvelle exposition intitulée pas le
temps pour l'amour histoire de
survivants de l'holocauste lors de
l'inauguration de cette exposition le
grand rabbin de russie mais aussi les
ambassadeurs en russie de l'allemagne
des etats-unis et d'israël ont tour à
tour pris la parole pour rendre hommage
aux victimes bien entendu mais aussi
pour souligner qu'il était nécessaire de
continuer à combattre l'antisémitisme
encore aujourd'hui l'exposition en
elle-même est composé d'extraits de
journaux intimes de mémoire ou de
biographies publiées ces vingt dernières
années par d'anciens prisonniers des
camps de concentration des combattants
juifs de la résistance ou encore par
leurs enfants ou petits-enfants
l'événement présente aussi des oeuvres
de l'artiste français christian
boltanski
du sculpteur polonais miroslaw balka ou
encore des installations d'artistes
contemporains israéliens à travers ses
oeuvres d'art est le récit de ses onze
histoires d'amour des histoires d'amour
qui ont su exister malgré les immenses
difficultés cette exposition propose
ainsi de nouvelles perspectives pour
parler du traumatisme est du devoir de
mémoire et xenia alcôves a été arrêtée
avec sa mère et sa soeur pendant la
répression du soulèvement de varsovie
transféré à auschwitz puis au camp de
neuengamme à près de hambourg elle
témoigne aujourd'hui il ne rêvait pas
d'eau il n'y avait rien à manger quand
on m'a demandé ce que j'avais mangé j'ai
répondu je ne m'en souviens pas je ne
mangeais rien en outre nous avons
participé de manière très active à cette
lutte contre les allemands plus tard les
soldats venait moins souvent parce que
nous étions exposés au score but à la
dystrophie on avait des poux et il
n'avait rien à manger ni à boire les
gens mouraient et une creuser des tombes
là sur le terrain y a plein les ouvrir
et après l'enterrement ont creusé des
fausses tout près de ses thons à trouver
de l'eau bien sûr les gens tomber malade
d'abate on est déjà fin septembre c'est
la fin de l'insurrection de varsovie
ils ont jeté des tracts trois fois et
les gens sortent et il était écrit dans
ses tracts grand défi sinon tout
varsovie sera réduit en cendres à ceux
qui se rendront nous allons garantir la
vie et une existence normale
[Musique]
l'audio il ya une heure de calme ni les
allemands ni les polonais ne tirait les
gens sortent et il tenait leur foulard
vous voyez les gens vont marcher dans
les ruines leur foulard à la main cette
situation s'est répétée deux fois au
cours de ces deux mois à la fin du
troisième mois fin septembre ils ont
jeté les tracts pour la dernière fois à
hydro christophe dépasse les 10
il n'y avait presque personne
nous avions une maison et un jardin
quand les allemands rendez vous sinon
nous allons tous vous détruire les
identités de 76 mille juifs déportés ils
sont inscrits il s'agit du mur des noms
de la même au mémorial de la shoah à
paris
un monument fraîchement rénové qu
emmanuel macron inauguré aujourd'hui 175
nom ayant été rajoutés la visite du chef
de l'elysée intervient quelques jours
après son déplacement en israël pour le
rassemblement d'une quarantaine de chefs
d'état en hommage aux victimes de la
shoah
c'est demain que débutera le procès
intenté par les ex salariés de goodyear
après des années de luttes ces derniers
restent déterminés un point final à des
années d'audience et de manifestations
le point avec mona amont dès lors le 14
janvier 2014 l'usiné de pneumatiques
goodyear d'amiens-nord fermait laissant
sur le carreau plus de 1100 43 salariés
six ans plus tard la bataille judiciaire
est loin d'être terminée le 28 janvier
843 ex goodyear ont rendez vous devant
le conseil de prud'hommes
les plaignants contestent le caractère
économique de leur licenciement
c'est le plus gros procès aux
prud'hommes de france si l'on a pris on
oublie riant les pluies sont toujours
les mêmes ouverte béante à vif une
fermeture d'usiné c'est pour celles et
ceux qui la subissent une violence
absolue
surtout quand il n'y a absolument aucune
justification économique et que
l'acharnement du groupe à détruire le
personnel a laissé des traces à tout
jamais ce dossier est devenu au fil du
temps de plus en plus sensibles car
l'usiné devenue un symbole politique et
sociale c'est en effet sur ce site que
françois hollande alors en campagne
s'était rendu en octobre 2011 pour
défendre les licenciements boursiers une
promesse de campagne qui ne s'est jamais
concrétisée alors les années passent
mais la lutte continue pour les ex
salariés actions coup-de-poing
manifestations rassemblements ou encore
interview télévisée
et quelques années plus tard en 2016 sur
rmc emmanuel macron alors ministre de
l'économie deux françois hollande
s'était confronté à mickaël wamen ex
leader de la cgt de goodyear amiens nord
et entend dire que l'échangé était des
plus tendues ça n'existe pas d'interdire
du licenciement ou alors vous vivez dans
une économie fermée administrés ça n'est
pas l'économie française fasse un nombre
de plaignants le conseil des prud'hommes
d'amiens a été obligé de déplacer
l'audience dans le zénith de la ville
nous allons démontrer que nous avons été
victimes d'une stratégie de
délocalisation purement financière la
justice est longue très longue trop
longue mais nous ne lâcherons jamais et
nous obtiendrons le jugement qui viendra
nous dire qu'il n'ya jamais eu de
justification économique pour nos
licenciements
rappelons qu'en octobre 2018 les
conseillers prud'homaux damien n'avait
pas pu se mettre d'accord sur les
demandes des ex-salariés de vous dire
qu'ils réclamaient réparation du
préjudice subi pour leur licenciement
c'est donc un juge départiteur qu'un
magistrat professionnel qui devra rendre
le verdict à l'issue de cette nouvelle
audience
et pour l'ancien délégué cgt goodyear
michael va mène les salariés ont les
preuves matérielles nécessaires pour
faire plier la multinationale américaine
et obtenir des indemnités conséquentes
l'année de la fermeture d'usinés en 2014
pour donner quelques chiffres
goodyear a annoncé à la presse
économique puisqu'il est obligé de
balancer des chiffres la presse
économique en fin d'année que le
résultat net après impôt du coup dur
était de 3,5 milliards de dollars après
impôts et qu'il a versé plus de 5
milliards de dividendes aux actionnaires
donc nous aujourd'hui légitimement bien
dit n y avait pas de motif économique à
la fermeture d'une usine puisque l'année
où il vient fermer son usine il fait des
chiffres records et depuis d'ailleurs il
ne cesse de battre ses propres chiffres
puisque depuis maintenant au bout de
leurs familles une usine en moyenne par
an six ans après c'est non on va venir
dire à la justice on vous demande
d'examiner tous les documents que nous
avons eu et c'est pas sans peine on a
mis énormément de temps à cuba les
documents que goodyear voulait pas nous
donner maintenant comprend pourquoi
quand on les regarde on a les preuves
matérielles que cette fermeture est en
réalité une délocalisation comme tant
d'autres mais avec quelque chose d
extrêmement frauduleux c'est-à-dire que
goodyear a complètement masquer le fait
est l'évidence même que il a cherché à
travers des salariés les syndicats
un argument qui était de dire on a
refusé un changement dans les dix
nations du temps de travail que donc il
fallait qu'ils ferment nos usines
mais en réalité depuis le début des
années 2000 goodyear avait planifié la
fermeture de notre site
maintenant ce qu'on veut c'est obtenir
des années mythiques complémentaires il
ya eu le plan de sauvegarde de l'emploi
d'ailleurs les mots ont leur importance
mais quand j'entends parler aujourd'hui
de plan de sauvegarde de l'emploi ça me
fait bondir parce qu'en fin de compte on
n'a rien sauvegarder le tout le monde a
été viré donc ça c'est de la sémantique
un peu nous tendance un peu nouvelle
maintenant ce qu'on doit on vient
réclamer ces indemnités complémentaires
à peu près quatre ans de salaire en
moyenne par salarié
ce qui n'est pas rien mais en tout état
de cause ne donnera pas notre boulot
mais par contre ça peut nous permettre
de tourner la page définitivement parce
que c'était très douloureux c'était très
long et toujours en france qu ils sont
des dizaines à s'être rassemblés ce soir
devant le théâtre bobino à paris des
gilet jaune qui se sont donnés rendez
vous devant la salle qui accueille un
meeting de benjamin griveaux objectifs
affichés pour les mines temps perturbé
la fête et rappeler leur vif désaccord
avec la politique du gouvernement
qu'est ce qu'on peut faire à part à part
un réveil citoyen
à part descendre dans la rue pour
contester je pense que alors on n'a pas
d'autre choix à l'heure actuelle on n'a
plus d'autre choix
il a les mêmes idées que macro ça se
voit de toute façon moi ça c'est clair
il ne peut pas aller contre de toute
façon le président c'est pas possible
donc forcément il marche du même côté a
à ce moment de dire si la république en
marche et nous on est content on n'a pas
du tout envie
56e jours de contestation contre la
réforme des retraites est 48 heures
d'une nouvelle mobilisation nationale à
l'appel de l'intersyndicale ce sont les
avocats qui se sont entendus aujourd'hui
elle semblait générale du barreau de
seine-saint-denis a voté cet après midi
à bobigny la poursuite de la grève
le conseil national des barreaux appel
de son côté toutes les robes noires à
participer à une manifestation nationale
à paris lundi prochain à écouter leurs
revendications
la revendication principale elle est
évidemment
retrait du projet de retraite
actuellement à l'examen
au gouvernement déposé par le
gouvernement l'examen à l'assemblée
nationale et
plus généralement ce problème de
retraite
et
la face immergée de l'iceberg
on se rend compte que en réalité un
véritable problème en france avec la
justice de ce pays
une justice qui manque de moyens à une
justice qui ne peut pas travailler
convenablement et on le voit bien
puisque aujourd'hui lorsque les avocats
sont en grève dans trois semaines comme
c'est le cas on entame la quatrième
semaine les tribunaux s'engorge
les audiences
surcharge on a fait rare des mois de
février et mars pour être très remplie
et donc la justice ne fonctionne pas et
en fait nous ce qu'on voudrait essayer
de faire comprendre c'est qu'au delà du
combat des avocats contre le projet de
réforme il ya un véritable combat glos
plus globale sur l'état de la justice en
france est
les moyens qui sont donnés dans ce pays
à la justice pour travailler et aux
avocats travaillent et la réforme des
retraites au coeur d'une conférence ce
matin entre syndicats et retraités
présents une dizaine de membres de
différentes associations syndicats
d'écouter certains d'entre eux nos
revendications et bien c'est
d'arrêter s'arrêter là je parle en tant
que retraité d'arrêter et puis de nous
expliquer exactement quelle en est la
loi car quand on lit les articles on a
beau lire lire plusieurs fois
eh bien on a du mal à les comprendre et
puis on voit eux-mêmes'' le gouvernement
demande aux syndicats de trouver du
financement donc est-ce qu'ils n'ont pas
trouvé d'autres financements
on voit le conseil d'état aussi qui se
pose des questions on voit vent et donc
c'est pas très clair franchement pas
très clair très opaque et donc il vaut
mieux prendre un peu de souffle et puis
réfléchir un peu plus sur le long terme
a diminué de 25% à 30%
les revenus des retraités même si on
tape sur les plus riches
ça veut dire quand même un
appauvrissement général de 16 millions
de personnes bientôt 17 bientôt 18 et
que ce point de vue là c'est quand même
un impact considérable pour la société
je pense qu'on n'a pas encore bien
réaliser que ce n'est pas un changement
technique
c'est en fait un changement de société
et que cette société là ça n'a plus rien
à voir avec celle que nous avons connue
construite en 1945 avec un système de
retraites destinées à redonner aux
retraités qui était à l'époque
très bien très pénalisés de redonner un
niveau de vie à peu près qui venant
celui des selleries londres entre eux
vendredi soir entre un vendredi soir à
23h dans la période de transition post
break site jusqu'à la fin de l'année
le royaume uni et l'union européenne
doivent négocier de nouvelles relations
commerciales en attendant le négociateur
en chef de l'ue mettent en garde contre
une rupture brutale et michel barnier a
cueilli tout à l'heure à dublin par le
premier ministre irlandais qui jugent le
royaume uni en position de faiblesse en
vue de futures négociations
nous devions tout d'abord organiser ce
break si ce retrait bien organisé et
c'est fait je pense que c'est fait le
premier round est terminé maintenant et
nous devons tout reconstruire
je pense que si vous considérez cela
comme un concours l'union européenne est
en position de force
nous sommes 27 pays nous avons une
population de 450 millions de personnes
et le marché unique est la plus grande
économie du monde
mais je ne pense pas qu'il faille y voir
cela comme un concours nous avons la
possibilité de travailler ensemble
le royaume uni ou pour des prochains
mois et d'établir une relation future et
un accord commercial qui soit
mutuellement bénéfique et c'est dans cet
esprit que nous allons entamer ces
discussions est le break ci doit
maintenant s'organiser cela pourrait
prendre du temps en selon david xavier
weiss auteur du break site et après aux
éditions barten jones sur le bilan pour
le pour le pour la grande bretagne je
pense qu'il n'est pas si optimiste que
ça si on regarde les choses en face
on va avoir une grande bretagne qui va
être éclaté avec une demande d'audition
de la barre de l'ecosse de l'irlande
que va devenir l'irlande on a donc un
problème institutionnel on aura aussi un
problème économique parce que le coût du
bric cité la préparation du président de
ces trois années de divorce donc à
l'amiable est un peu brutal
ça a coûté l'équivalent de quarante sept
annuités de financement au budget
européen
donc la grande bretagne a perdu en trois
ans 47 fois le budget qu'elle y mettait
pour la pour la construction reprenne
maintenant c'est un choix il ya il ya eu
un choix clair des ddd britannique il on
a voulu ce divorce
il va falloir maintenant l'organiser et
l'organiser ça va aussi prendre beaucoup
de temps
près de son entrée au sein de la cee en
1973 a aujourd'hui londres a souvent
entretenu des relations houleuses avec
bruxelles retour en images
[Musique]
dix chevaux
les ambitions nationales de matteo
salvini contrarié par le scrutin local
en emilie romagne la ligue de l'ex vice
premier ministre italien s'incline face
à la gauche
jordi demory il avait annoncé en cas de
victoire de son camp la démission de
l'exécutif et des législatives
anticipées
mais le parti de matteo salvini a été
battu par la gauche ce dimanche en
emilie romagne dans le nord du pays
selon des résultats partiels
ce scrutin régional avait valeur de test
national pour le leader souverainiste
italien le président sortant de la
région stefano bonacci ni du parti
démocrate de centre gauche a devancé
avec un score autour de 50% des voix son
adversaire lucia bourgogne zoni la
représentant de la ligue serait telle
crédité d'environ 43% des suffrages
selon les premiers dépouillements des
bulletins de vote
attention talent une chose ressort je ne
suis pas intéressé pour commenter les
problèmes des autres
cependant il est clair que l'un des deux
alliés du gouvernement je pense aux
mouvements 5 étoiles si les données sont
confirmées disparaît en grande partie de
la région emilie romagne et il disparaît
également presque de la région de
calabre
deux des régions le mouvement 5 étoiles
est née et où il a recueilli le plus de
voix
il est donc clair que quelque chose va
changer demain à rome
cette élection régionale a été marquée
par une très forte participation de 67%
contre 37 lors du précédent scrutin de
2014 régions prospères du centre nord de
la péninsule l'émilie romagne a
longtemps été un bastion historique de
la gauche
outre la forte affluence aux urnes la
gauche a aussi profité de la dynamique
antistalinienne créé par les sardines un
mouvement de jeunes nés dans la région
est devenue un symbole national de la
protestation contre la droite
nationaliste iranien a indiqué s
attendre à des résultats il faut dire
aussi que ce fut pour moi un grand
résultat historique
c'est le résultat du nombre d'entre vous
qui êtes ici aujourd'hui et du fait que
pour la première fois dans l'histoire
après 50 ans
cette région était contestable
nous continuerons à travailler matteo
salvini a tenté de se consoler en se
réjouissant de la victoire quasiment
assuré de la candidat de centre droit
jole santelli lors d'élections
régionales organisées en calabre
compte tenu de son engagement au premier
plan dans ce scrutin la défaite en
emilie romagne est un revers important
pour la formation souverainiste
le leader de la ligue espérait en effet
une victoire afin de provoquer de
nouvelles élections qui lui permettrait
de revenir aux commandes du pays
au final le chef du gouvernement
giuseppe compter le parti démocrate
devrait être renforcée par cette
victoire de la gauche
le premier ministre italien justement
qui n'a pas tardé à réagir aux résultats
de ce scrutin elle qualifie matteo
salvini de grands perdants après ce vote
il y en a un qui a essayé de transformer
cette élection en référendum pour ou
contre le gouvernement
je parle de matteo salvini
pour moi son comportement est
inapproprié d'ailleurs il apparaît
maintenant comme le grand perdant de
cette compétition la réalité est là les
citoyens et les communautés locales ont
pris ce vote comme un référendum sur lui
et il a perdu pertes ambrose à l avocat
et analyse de la politique italienne
selon lui ce résultat est un soulagement
pour l'europe et pour les marchés
financiers ce qui est plus beaucoup plus
surprenant c'est l'engagement que sabine
et avait pris d'une manière je dirais
qu'à second violente pour arriver à
vaincre et à battre la gauche dans cette
région et c'est un vrai échec parce
qu'il avait mis gérer tout son poids
physique moral humain politique pour
arriver à retourner ces situations et ça
c'est le premier point donc le bassin
res est de gauche mais je pense que
c'est plutôt un rééquilibrage
qu'aujourd'hui nous avons avec notamment
quelque chose que pour moi beaucoup plus
important aujourd'hui c'est vraiment le
moment cinq étoiles qui s'est écroulé et
aujourd'hui dans les deux régions
n'oublions pas que nous avons un
gouvernement avec le parti la gauche
le [ __ ] et les 5 étoiles et aujourd'hui
vous avez 4% à 5% aux 4,5 en attendant
le terme définitif à venir au mali et en
calabre et vous avez là le vrai échec je
pense retentissant dans cette affaire je
pense que le résultat que nous avons eu
aujourd'hui en italie est un soulagement
pour l'europe est un soulagement je
dirais pour les marchés financiers et le
besoin d'une certaine continuité
une situation je dirais de rééquilibrage
et il est clair qu'aujourd'hui
selon moi c'est mon opinion personnelle
mais c'est pour ça que je m'exprime avec
force c'est que on n'est pas près
d'aller aux nouvelles élections
c'est la fin de cette édition merci de
l'avoir suivi prochain rendez vous
demain 7h du matin heure française avec
l'actuel
[Musique]
à